[Musique]
jérémy ferrari bonsoir mais françois
gourd selon pour hugues moutouh recevons
pour une chaîne internet s'appelle
situant view nous sommes en direct est
ce que tu peux te présenter
succinctement je m'appelle jérémy
ferrari et je suis humoriste
c'est producteur
comédien voilà j'ai plusieurs plusieurs
petites activités comme ça annexes mais
je suis avant tout avant que humoristes
on est très content de te recevoir
aujourd'hui petites précautions
oratoires parce que c'est l'époque qui
veut ça et comme tu touche à des sujets
qui sont très touchy en ce moment pas de
diffamation pas de trucs pas sourcée
attention procès l'industrie
pharmaceutique ism patrons pénibles
première question
tspectacle surtout le dernier et l'avant
d'année est-ce que tu les fais relire
par un avocat scott obligé de la faire
relire par un avocat parce que tu as
peur de prendre un procès parce que tu
nages des trucs tellement énorme
tellement surréaliste est ce que tu es
obligé de te faire relire par un service
juridique oui alors je suis pas obligé
je pourrais y aller comme ça le renverra
vers mais non je fais relire quand même
enfin on fait relire par mon par mon
avocat
et il nous donne un peu la proportion tu
vois il va nous dire
le dire ça ça par exemple si tu le dis
tu risques ça si tu dis ça et après moi
je jauge quoi jusqu'à présent j'ai
jamais rien couper 1 après de temps en
temps le tue c'est en fait c'est quand
même compliqué de m'attaquer en justice
parce que souvent je change de sujet
donc moi je suis moi si je suis à la
place des mecs si je suis à la place des
mecs que j'attaque je me dis bon qu'est
ce qu'on fait déjà faut savoir que quand
j'attaque un sujet j'ai d'autres
dossiers c'est pas lui mais que tu
attaques c'est le sujet c'est le sujet
mais parfois tu vois sur quand quand
parfois je cite des noms ça m'est arrivé
souvent dre encore dans nouveau
spectacle de citer des noms de citer des
noms bois de citer des mecs et au machin
mais en réalité c'est compliqué de
m'attaquer en justice parce que en tout
cas moi je le redis attaqué - justice
parce que de toute façon je suis sûr de
mes sources 90% de mes sources ça vient
d'eux où des mecs qui travaillent pour
eux donc je sais très bien ce que je dis
et en plus j'ai souvent d'autres
dossiers donc si tu m'attaques en
justice tu peux être certain que je vais
tout sortir donc du coup pour le moment
personne n'a attaqué parce que je pense
qu'ils se sont dit de toute façon il
fait un spectacle ça va durer deux trois
ans laissons passer la tempête et puis
après une fois que le truc sera fini on
dira que c'était pas vrai où on sortira
2 3 bout du compte rond sortira deux
trois extraits du contexte en répondant
uniquement à une ou deux attaqué en
disant que tout le reste était faux et
puis voilà façon moi je suis après je
suis passé sur un autre dose donc je
vais pas revenir à l'attack tu vois donc
généralement pour l'instant il s ils
laissent passer et après de temps en
temps ça va être des petits trucs qu'ils
ont à me dire bon voilà ces injures
publiques voilà moi je republie que
c'est c'est rien tu au process et ses
500 balles c'est pas grave tu vas mai
mais encore une fois il aurait droit de
le faire tu vois je les attaque ils ont
le droit de se défendre mais pour le
moment ce n'est pas arrivé j'ai pas eu
de menaces on est venu me voir de temps
en temps pour me faire comprendre que ça
serait bien que j'arrête pour mon bien
c'est vrai problème et mais allons en
justice quel sujet robel notamment les
ong et tout ça quand j'ai attaqué les
ong on m'a fait comprendre gentiment n'y
a pas eu de ya pas eu de menaces au sens
au sens propre j'ai eu des menaces mais
les menaces étaient toujours anonymes
mais les ong c'est arrivé qui est des
gens qui est de me voir dans mon post
pour cette ong ce serait bien d'arrêter
parce que c'est plus compliqué que ça
j'ai pas mal compliqué que ça je fais un
sketch de 30 minutes sur vous avec vos
sources donc si vous n'êtes plus kitsch
tu vas plus que de l'écrire non mais
avec leurs sources donc c'est la même
chose tu vois c'est que c'est que c'est
très compliqué d'aller devant un juge de
dire ce qu'ils disent c'est pas vrai
alors que alors que tu sors les infos de
leur dossier tu vois c'est très très
compliqué quand même parce qu'en fait ce
qu'elle souhaite quand même dans ce
monde qui est quand même compliqué un
peu chaotique parfois un peu un peu dur
et tout c'est que tu as quand même des
mecs qui sont à des postes et qui sont
pas ultra à l'aise avec trucks qui font
tous les jours qu'ils soient un peu tu
vois qui s'est un peu là ils sont devant
leur miroir il fera [__] je suis
peut-être un petit peu reculé mais pas
complètement épuisé c'est beaucoup de
pas de gros bobos pas des robots pardon
je suis peut-être un petit peu un gredin
je suis peut-être un peu je sais pas
j'ai pas synonyme de recul et donc je
suis peut-être pas quelqu'un de
complètement bien il regarde ses gosses
plaisir parce qu'il serait fier de moi
six
journées alors il rationalise ses bons
puis de temps en temps et puis alors moi
j'arrive tout cas la poche du pourriez
m'aider ça c'est peut-être un petit
occasion de me racheter je vais lui
filer 2-3 dauger sortir de trois noms je
vais donner deux trois numéros et voilà
parce qu'il ya il n'y a pas que c'est ce
monde n'est pas n'est pas n'est pas tenu
que par des gens mauvais il ya aussi des
gens parfois un peu qu'ils sont faits
embrigader tu vois moi j'ai parlé avec
des gens et toi aussi certainement des
gens qui sont fondamentalement des gens
des gens bien mais qui font des choses
pas bien mais en fait c'est petit à
petit tu vois il a commencé à 19 ans il
était plein d'idéaux et puis on lui dit
tu sais si tu veux pouvoir faire ça
ferait que tu acceptes de lâcher sur ça
et tu lâches sur ça car un moment donné
tu te retrouves à 40 ans [__] super
train de vie tut aperçu que le train de
vie il est payé en grande partie des 80
% des choses que tu as accepté de lâcher
et puis après tu as des gosses et du coq
tueur est donc souvent ces gens là ils
sont à même ils ont envie de parler ils
ont envie de ça ils ont envie de se
confier et c'est la touche pour les
infos quoi là ton dernier spectacle tu
parles de quoi danser quoi les
principaux sujets que tu abordes est la
question que je vais te poser tout de
suite après c'est comment tu as fait
pour bosser est-ce que tu as une
expérience de terrain est en immersion
temps immersion est ce que c'était ce
qu'on t'a nourri dossier ce que c'est
arrivé je t'écoute alors ce spectacle
donc s'installer sur la santé il
s'appelle anesthésie générale
c'est un c'est un spectacle qui traite
de plein de sujets de la plein de sujets
divers et variés de la santé je voulais
traiter au tout départ ce spectacle tout
au départ je voulais d'abord traité de
du problème immense delà de la chute de
l'hôpital de l'hôpital public alors là
on doit se dire ah bah oui mais ça c'est
un sujet qu'on connaît bien oui mais moi
j'avais commencé avant le coc vide
j'avais quand j'avais écrit ce spectacle
avant le copie parce qu'il y avait déjà
un gros problème et à chaque fois tu
sais que j'ai un thème de ce spectacle
je tombe un mois ou deux avant un drama
bien c'est encore arrivé avec ce
spectacle j'ai commencé anesthésie
générale et puis il ya eu cette grève
historique d urgence en france donc
c'était avant le covin je reprécise
abstrait important de se rappeler que
les soignants étaient dans la rue à ce
moment là pour déjà réclamé des moyens
supplémentaires et c'est donc donc j'ai
donc j'ai créé un spectacle au tout
départ sur la santé de manière générale
les problèmes de santé des problèmes
d'investissement de 7 de ce service
public et puis après j'ai j'étais y est
tu vois c'est à dire que par exemple je
suis allé sur l'homéopathie parce que l
effort copain de mon bras si tu veux
parce que parce que je voulais en avant
d'en parler parce que c'est un sujet qui
pour moi est léger tu vois pas ce que
dans ce spectacle il faut aussi que tu
vois je j'oscille tu vois je fais des
sujets très dur des sujets plus légers
des machins bon voila mon fils il jx
alors voilà je me suis aperçu qu'en fait
c'était écrit j'ai tout laissé pour les
gens vu la réaction c'est que j'ai quand
même vu ça fait quand même douze ans
maintenant tu vois j'ai tout traité quoi
que ce soit à travers mes sketches à la
télévision à travers mes spectacles je
suis quand même allé dans tous les to
fait tu vois à peu son spoiler parce
qu'il faut il faut qu'on arrive à
connecter les gens avec ça parce que là
on fait comme des prize jo puisque moi
j'ai vu le délire c'est que si les dix
posticheurs leach de l'homéopathie
peuvent le voir juste moins content
explique le dosage de la pseudo
molécules actives alors là déjà je me
dis ouah et ensuite quand explique
le principe actif qui est censé être
dedans comme genre là glandes anales de
ce que donnerait le mesf it is plutôt
rieussec de la glande annales depuis
trois mois j'ai pu tout léger plus tous
les maux dans la tête parce que ça c'est
un truc que je lis pilager pas joué
depuis un mois et demi mais on fait de
la glande annales du plutôt de la glande
annales de putois du crachat de
coqueluche et
il ya du j'appelle aussi du plus de
beats est une espèce de ils prennent des
matchs ils prennent des matières de gens
qui ont des infections sexuelles s'il ya
de tout alors l'homéopathie pourquoi moi
j'ai traité l'homéopathie parce que ça
générait beaucoup de débats avec le
déremboursement machin et où puis je me
suis moi j'aime bien tu vois les sujets
où on sait pas vraiment c'est dès que ça
relève un peu de la croyance dès que tu
vois que dans un repas de famille et à
la boîte à la salle à moitié de saison
que qui sont pour la moitié de taiso
trous qui sont contre je suis ça c'est
intéressant parce qu en fait personne
n'en sait rien tant à partir du moment
où dans une même pièce tu as trois avis
différent c'est qu'en réalité personne
n'en sait rien et ça c'est quand même 90
% des sujets on creuse pas le truc tu
vois
et puis j'avais déjà vu quelques trucs
ou jeu j'avais entendu parler de la
dilution disait il ya vraiment rien
dedans mais tu vas ce qu'est ce que ça
veut dire rien dans ses cordes les mecs
qui me disait rien dans l'homéopathie
mais c'est quoi rien il ya quoi rien et
en fait quand tu creuses il n'y a
vraiment rien c'est pas ya peu du tracé
c'est ce que j'explique vraiment pour le
sida cocq-sida mlle si le coq scène
c'est une dilution à 200k donc 200 cas
c'est l'équivalent tu prends une goutte
de foie de canard putréfiés quelle est
la substance active 2 2 le célécoxib
hommes qui la met dans un litre et demi
d'eau pure
jusqu'où la bouteille c'est la
dynamisation
tu la ville la même bouteille que david
et hulard rempli d'un litre et demi tu
fais ça 200 fois
et là tu as la dilution pour le silo
maximum donc on est con est sûre on est
on est pas on est sur quelque quand j'ai
lu s'agit mais c'est pas possible
c'est impossible j'ai mal lu ses bas
vous géré creuser rose c'est vraiment ça
on est sur une dilution jeudi dans le
spectacle c'est l'équivalent on a
calculé mathématiquement ce que ça
représentait c'est l'équivalent d'un
atome alors peut-être même ses plus
petits qu'un atome on ne peut pas savoir
parce que il n'y a pas d'unité de mesure
plus petit que l'atome mais dont on va
dire donc c'est l'atome et peut-être que
les laboratoires boiron sont légèrement
gagnant sur ce semestre
des laboratoires 1
donc c'est l'équivalent d'un atome de
foie de canard dans cinq fois l'univers
visible
c'est pas beaucoup quoi
donc voilà après et après après encore
une fois moi j'essaie toujours d'être
d'être de rester objectif que je suis
pas dans j'essaye de paille dans le
jugement des gens tu as l'air que moi ce
que je dis c'est en gros moi je m'en
fous que les gens prennent de
l'oscillococcinum aura été jo je m'en
tape complètement j'en prenais
oscillococcinum bon les gens pour qui ça
marche on sait que c'est de l'effet
placebo mais aller mais peu importe en
mieux est ce que tu es tombé sur des
études où il ya
preuve de l'efficacité pas de
l'efficacité a pas d'étude
il n'y a pas d'étude mecs tu étudiés tu
as peut être unie carafe d'eau il n'y a
pas d'étude d'ailleurs ça peut être mis
en pharmacie sans tests toxicologiques
sans tests pharmacologiques sans rien il
n'y a rien il n'y a pas d'étude la seule
chose que dit la loi là dessus sur le
truc de la santé c'est
espèce de code pénal de la santé ce
qu'il dit c'est que en gros ils ont
droit de commercialiser sans aucun test
ci respecte la tradition de fabrication
homéopathiques et la tradition de
fabrication de nos pratiques c'est ce
que je viens de te dire donc en gros un
certain taux de dilution ils peuvent
commercialiser sentent est
vidé de son sens quand tu fais un
plaisir inouï ouais alors il se trouve
que lui il est vraiment homéopathe mais
en plus c'est un copain
maîtriser quoi il a réagi de la
meilleure des manières qui soit il a
rigolé là j'ai encore des années qu a
pas longtemps ils m'ont juste dit très
drôle le sketch qu est ce qu on a rigolé
tu vois il n'a pas mais parce que
parce que je peux comprendre la démarche
que je verse et gréements je suis pas
dans le jugement des gens comprennent
moi pourquoi j'ai fait ça parce que
parce qu'ils sont allés plus loin que ça
ils ont fait ils ont ce une assoc
une espèce de ong où ils ont distribué
de l'homéopathie en faisant payer les
gens dans des pays compliqué où déjà les
gens n'ont pas d'argent il il ya
certains il ya certes un certain groupe
d'homéopathie qui font des choses qui à
mon sens relève vraiment du
charlatanisme que les gens de leur plein
gré achète de l'homéopathie parce qu'ils
ont l'impression que ça leur fait du
bien et très certainement que ça leur
fait du bien parce que l'effet placebo
c'est quelque chose de réel je sais
qu'il ya plein d'hommes sans crainte
certainement de s'exciter en disant
qu'il est fou et des fous que tu sois
toujours les arguments de ces mieux
prendre sacd et mais des vrais
médicaments déjà j'ai tout entendu mais
moi ya pas de problème moi après mon job
c'est de prendre un truc et de voix et
de dire la vérité aux gens moi j'ai fait
que dire la vérité aux gens après ce qui
m'embête pourquoi j'ai pris ce sujet
parce qu'ils étaient remboursés par la
sécurité sociale et en 2019 j'ai fait le
calcul c'est l'équivalent du salaire de
2000 infirmières alors que nos
infirmières à l'heure actuelle même avec
le ségur même avec la petite
augmentation qu'ils ont eu elles sont
toujours payés moins que la moyenne
européenne
le pouvoir d'achat d'une infirmière en
france est moindre que celui du pouvoir
d'achat d'une infirmière mexicaine donc
moi je m'en fous que les gens prennent
de l'homéopathie ici ils peuvent aller
se frotter sur des cordes de licorne si
sage et si sa mère voiture je m'en tape
complètement mais qui va me dire moi je
vois des nains dans la forêt une froide
des pierres et puis ça ne guérit va
gérer cette formidable continuer d'aller
voir ces nains
ont même moi même si je m'en fous
complètement tu vois mais il faut pas
que ça rentre dans un système où l'état
commence à rembourser ça parce que ça
relève plus de la croyance tu vois donc
à partir de mousse est une croyance
chacun fait ce qu'il veut mais pas avec
la colonne l'argent collectif et
sur d'autres sujets tu t'es mis en
immersion tu as été voir comment ça se
passait est-ce que ce que tu ton passif
est ce que tu hypocondriaque pas
hypocondriaque est-ce que tu creuses des
sujets pourquoi tu creuses ces sujets
est pourquoi tu vas dessus est pourquoi
l immersion pour que l'expérience du
terrain alors allez beaucoup de
questions alors
déjà pourquoi ce thème c'est déjà un
thème que sur lequel j'avais envie de
travailler quand j'ai entendu que vide
pas qu'on parle du comité tués quand
j'ai écrit vent de pièces à beyrouth
donc le spectacle précédent pour ceux
qui me l'ont pas suivi forcément j'avais
un spectacle avant donc sur la
géopolitique j'hésitais déjà entre la
géopolitique les attentes à tous afin
tout ce truc là et la santé et puis mon
instinct à ce moment là m'a dit non plus
tôt la géopolitique parce que je sentais
tu avec le printemps arabe y avait plein
de chauffage sentait qu'il y avait un
truc et puis ben malheureusement
quelques mois plus tard il y aura le
bataclan enfin voilà comme d'habitude à
chaque fois j'arrive dans le thème
avant avant un drame
et donc donc le parti sur la
géopolitique donc je savais déjà que
j'allais aller sur la santé pourquoi la
santé parce que j'ai senti que les gens
commençaient à se poser des questions
j'ai senti dans l'air du temps qu'ils
ont commencé à se dire mais qu'est ce
que qu'est-ce que je m'entends fait
pourquoi il ya pourquoi tout le monde a
le cancer tue jamais entendu cette
phrase j'ai huit membres de la famille
1,4 qu'on le cancer
qui commet donc les gens ont commencé à
dire attends qu est ce qu est ce qu est
ce que je mange pourquoi je prends des
médicaments qu'est-ce que pourquoi le
sport tu sais avant se moquer des gens
qui mangent sainement qui faisait du
sport on disait que les gens étaient
chienlit et laet a senti bon je fais un
cliché tout le monde pensait pas ça mais
enfin on s'est compris on a senti que ça
commencé à basculer les gens ont
commencé à vouloir faire un peu plus
attention à eux et donc il ya une
sensibilité sur la santé en plus de d'un
vrai appels à l'aide du personnel
soignant à l'hôpital public criait au
secours on est en train de mourir on n'a
plus d'argent donc donc j'avais envie de
traiter le sujet et puis après je pense
qu on l'évoquera plus tard mais c'est
pour expliquer le cheminement complet je
vais pas rentrer dans les détails
maintenant mais j'ai fait moi
une tentative de suicide j'avais de gros
problèmes que je traînais avec l'alcool
etc et il se trouve que je l'aurais fait
de toute façon même sans cette
expérience mais il trouve que du coup
quand je me suis mis aux trucs sur la
santé au nouveau spectacle ce thème que
donc je voulais traiter depuis déjà
quelques années j'avais déjà de trois
ans de clean donc je buvais plus ni rien
j'avais vécu des trucs incroyables
personnellement et je me suis dit ben
c'est le moment d'en parler voilà donc
donc ça ça a été le premier cheminement
après j'ai fait comme d'habitude donc ce
que je fais c'est qu'en gros je
travaille en entonnoir alors que ça veut
dire qu'on est noir comme je ne connais
rien au sujet que j'utilise enfin que je
que je traite parce que je suis pas allé
à l'école je suis pas un érudit je suis
pas un intellectuel donc je suis je suis
plutôt un instinctif qui va vers les
trucs tu vois alors donc au début je me
dis ok pour moi qu'est ce que c'est la
santé alors je me fais des grands thèmes
comme ça donc je vais dire qu'il ya
cours alors les études pour faire la
santé l'économie de la santé les
nouvelles maladies les nouveaux trucs je
fais une espèce de truc comme ça on en
espère qu'après je fais de l'entonnoir
donc c'est à dire que je fais des sous
des sous thèmes de salé soutiennent de
ça des sous thèmes de sa pige traite
alors comment je traite des articles des
rencontres des coups de fil des
immersions etc puis après hop ya un
moment donné j arrive à un certain
nombre de sujets je me dis ok avec tous
ces sujets je traite à peu près tout ce
que je voulais dire les gens sont
toujours frustré c'est quand j'ai quand
parce que j'avais ouvert une boîte mail
en disant balances ton dos j'avais fait
un truc de balances ton dos points comme
un truc comme ça comme booba haye a fait
ça sa chair est pas un truc comme ça tu
vas je disais aux gens envoyez moi vos
expériences
envoyez moi un petit peu ce que vous
avez vécu les sujets que vous aimeriez
qu'on traite et tout mais le problème
c'est que la santé c'est tellement
personnel je me suis retrouvé avec 755
sujet tu vois pas ce que donc tu peux
pas satisfaire tout le monde tout cas il
va me dire mais pourquoi t'as pas parler
de je sais pas pourquoi tu as parlé de
cette maladie pourquoi t'as pas parler
de l'épilepsie personnes parlent de
l'épilepsie tu vois tu as toujours des
gens un peu déçu mais ça c'est surtout
les thèmes donc ce qu'il faut faire
c'est prendre les thèmes qui te permet
de traiter le propos général qu'est ce
que tu veux dire tu vois et donc j'ai
fait de l'immersion pour voir si c'était
vraiment à ce point la merde dans les
hôpitaux parce que c'est toujours ils
font mais quand on travaille comme ça il
faut il faut jamais se dire il faut a
priori les médecins ils sont gentils a
priori le personnel soignant il est
gentil a priori
c'est a priori l'état doit effectivement
pas leur donner de thunes mais il faut
pas y aller dans cette optique là parce
que sinon tu n'es pas objectif et
tueries de louper des choses donc il
faut y aller il faut se méfier des deux
de la même manière même si c'est très
dur parce que tu as pris ta médecin
d'une infirmière qui dit avec 4 je fais
souvent 17 heures je fais en 17 heures
par semaine je dors de rumba site
factice en peux plus je vais crever bon
ba hy la vente la plus d'empathie pour
elle mais il faut essayer de pas d'y
aller comme ça et donc je suis allé voir
donc je suis allée faire notamment celle
aux urgences donc j'ai fait plusieurs
immersion j'en ai fait une aux urgences
classique tu vois je dirai pas le nom
des hôpitaux parce qu'il n'est pas trop
le droit d'être là donc donc je vais pas
fait balancer mais j'ai fait les
urgences classique et puis j'ai fait les
urgences psychiatrique parce que je
voulais la psychiatrie m'intéresse
beaucoup donc je voulais aller voir etc
et c'est et c'est dramatique c'est
dramatique c'est tu sais je dois surtout
après le colis de
confinement alors moi je l' ai vu avant
et c'était déjà dramatique puisque après
du coup c'était tellement dramatique au
léman ni mes lampes on peut même pas de
prendre ces c'est trop et c'est
réglé on peut même pas tout on peut même
pas on peut même pas d'invités c'est
trop vite a vu ce que tu as vu battu
multiplie par dix et à ce qui se passe
quoi et tu sais c'est exactement la même
chose
je passe tu te souviens mais dont je
crois que j'avais dit ça chez toi sur la
guerre faisait moi ça m'intéresse de
savoir je vois que des victimes tu vois
quand je vois de deux camps s'affrontent
et je vois que des victimes j'avais dit
ça sur le conflit israélo palestinien
que j'avais traité dans le précédent
spectacle je vais rencontrer des soldats
israéliens les soldats palestiniens et à
la fin même si même si dans ta tête tu
arrives avec plein de certitudes plein
d'à priori en disant je pense que lui et
plus méchant que l'autre et où en
réalité quand à parler avec les deux à
la fin tu dit mme [__] en fait il ya
que deux victimes c'est horrible en fait
qui est le gars qui a mis ces deux mecs
l'un en face de l'autre et sur la guerre
j'étais arrivé à ça eh bien c'est
exactement la même jeu de la même chose
que j'ai vécue dans les urgences c'est à
dire que
donc moi j'avais accès aux deux que donc
je suis dit à la salle attend des
urgences et puis en gros tapis tu passes
la porte et pitt à l'hôpital derrière tu
vois en gros les services de soins avec
le personnel tu sais
quand je suis là ça va je suis souvent
le card je sais pas ce qu'ils payent ces
actifs gratuit en janvier beaucoup mais
met
donc telle résurgence alors donc tu
arrives moi je suis resté une nuit
complète donc je suis arrivé en fin
d'après midi je suis resté jusqu'au
matin
et donc tu as des gens qui arrivent jour
quel jour
un soir de pleine lune ou pas un super
papa
je crois à je suis pas sûr tu me fais
pas je crois pas
je crois parce que j'ai bien dormi je
dors pas bien je crois pas
non mais bon en tout cas il y avait il y
avait du monde quoi et donc
effectivement tu vois de vraiment des
gens arriver à 17 18 heures une nuit une
heure qui sont encore là
alors tu as aussi les gens avec les
enfants ça c'est compliqué ça c'est très
compliqué parce que les gens avec les
enfants ce que je comprends j'ai pas
d'enfants mais je comprends ça pour eux
leurs enfants ça doit passer avant tout
tu vois il ya des gens ils ont encore un
peu de patience parfois pour eux mais
quand on a des enfants il ya donc bref
on va on va pas révoquer forcément on se
fait des enfants on va partir sur un
truc très basique tu as des gens qui
sont là qui ont mal alors des fois ça va
être un truc qui nécessitent pas d
urgentes des gens ils auraient pu
laisser le médecin mais bon c'est la
nuit donc tu as tous les cas tu as des
gens qui sont très blessé des gens tu
sais pas ce qu'ils ont tu vois pas ce
que tu as des gens ils sont comme ça tu
sais pas ce qu'ils ont bon voilà
et puis s'attendent par y en a qui
souffrent c'est un c'est un truc de
tension très forte sur [__] ils
partent avant d'autres donc les autres
comprennent pas pourquoi lui les partis
avant lui fin tu vois c'est un truc très
bizarre les gens se parlent pas à ford
et de l'autre côté tu as des infirmières
des médecins qui courent dans tous les
sens ils ont les yeux et on évalue que
tu les entends moi j'ai entendu des
appels de deux médecins dire enfin
d'infirmières dire est ce que tu peux
demander à tel hôpital de nous ramener
des pansements
plus de pansement alors j'ai pas il ya
peut-être un type spécifique de
pansements entre rarissime jean sérien
tu vois je te dis juste que j'ai entendu
je fais pas un jugement spécifique là
dessus mais c'est pour dire j'entendais
des phrases et je vois les gens qui sont
dans tous les sens et l'hôpital dans
lequel je suis allé c'est un hôpital qui
est plutôt bien lotis financièrement
donc j'ai pas vu le pire j'ai vu un truc
c'est totalement le moins pire je veux
couper bien sûr pendant ta nuit aux
urgences est ce que tu as vu là
réactions d'élus des services soignants
face à la misère du monde des tabacs
c'est exactement là je suis un petit peu
long c'était pour situer le contexte
mais c'est là où j'allais en venir c'est
que donc tu es l'infirmière cas pas
dormi de café 17 heures de suite qu'ils
essaient de trouver des pansements ils
courent dans tous les sens comme ça et
sous payés tu vois bon c'est la merde sa
vie à elle déjà les très compliqué est
arrivée comme une passion mais là
commencent à être fatigués ce qu'on
comprend tous elle arrive dans la salle
d'attenté tu vois elle ou quelqu'un
d'autre mot france comprend et là tu as
des patients qui donc payer des impôts
vont à l'hôpital public ils ont choisi
un hôpital qui est bien loties comme je
dis donc ils disent non ici je vais être
reçus et le gars souffrons lui a pas
parlé depuis 6 heures où cet homme vous
pouvez pas le faire et ils n'avaient je
suis témoin il ne pouvait pas le faire
il était trop occupé ailleurs hélas ces
deux personnes se rencontrent et là
c'est terrible
parce que tu as deux personnes qui se
détestent alors que les deux veulent la
même chose tu as vraiment un personnel
soignant passionnés qui fait vraiment
tout ce qui peut pour y arriver et un
patient qui à juste titre attend de se
faire recevoir et de recevoir des soins
dans un délais corrects et qu'il devrait
pas souffrir cette heure où 80 donc la
tasse et deux personnes qui se
rencontrent et çà et là ça part en
cacahuète les gens se détestent et et
encore une fois je ne vois que deux
victimes tu vois c'est exactement le
même principe que ce que je te
raconterai avant de pièces à beyrouth
s'est en fait je disais mais c'est
dramatique en fait alors tu as aussi des
gens tata d'état des gens c'est pas
systématique chez les infirmières qui
arrive à rester calme et puis des
patients qui sont non qui sont qui sont
si compréhensif mais tu as beaucoup de
tension il ya des agents de sécurité ou
dans les hôpitaux maintenant parce que
les jeunes y fait des câbles qu'ils
adressent les gens à dos c'est
ccc dramatique quand est ce que tu as vu
les sdf des bars qui en état d'urgence
lens plutôt aux urgences post us et
froid dehors ou douche toilettes à les
pompiers qui arrivent qui amène des gens
etc mais ça c'est plutôt ça j'ai vu mais
il s'est traité de manière très
c'est marrant en fait parce que ça je l'
ai vu une fois il traite ça avec
beaucoup de ces presque un membre de la
famille tu sais c'est presque le monde
de la famille qui a trop bu je dis pas
que le cfa est robuste et parce que je
veux dire mais tu sais c'est le principe
ah bah c'est presque comme s'ils se
connaissaient et étaient là bon allez
viens mon devoir tu vois il ya un côté
c'est ce qui est terrible aventure c'est
c'est presque le vip quoi tu vois il ya
un côté on voit on le voit souvent on
l'a déjà vu il revient encore du buzz it
et amélia que l'humanité mais même de
s'engueuler c'est très humain en réalité
c'est juste que c'est dramatique parce
que parce que tu dises et c'est bien
même si tu donnes des milliards aux
hôpitaux il y aura toujours des gens qui
sont pas contents des gens fatigués de
l'autre côté ça arrivera toujours mais
là c'est pas ça lasse et là c'est un
autre step est ce que tu as vu est ce
que tu as vu par exemple des urgences
chirurgicales débarquer le mec pas pris
en charge parce que l'équipe soit ne
pouvait pas genre une torsion
testiculaire qui débarque vous avoir
chaud ce qui devient du coup c'est la
première chose qui me vient c'est un
problème de couilles quoi j'ai pas
loisirs dont plus de tester
bien ce que ça
sathorn cette part non bah oui j'en ai
aussi qu'en détention
[Rires]
j'ai pas vu de trucs je n'ai pas vu mais
on mais j'ai pas j'ai pas vu un gars se
faire déprogrammer sous mes yeux ça je
n'ai pas vu mais je sais que ça arrive
parce qu'il me raconte pas ce que parce
que les parce que les médecins me l'ont
dit tu vois surtout pendant le coït ça
ça a été l'un des l'un des drames
c'était programmé les gens etc etc ça
c'est une réalité mais ce n'est pas que
pendant kaulitz était programmée ou
trier
tu comprends lagence je vais bien tu me
l'as précise pas ce qu'il ya ta manière
à toi de voir le tri du programme s
étaient obligés de
mais qui fait de la bobologie ou qui
vient faire point une une opération une
intervention son centre ou de qui peut
attendre
et trier c'est à dire papilles toi toi
que vides toi papy doit rester chez toi
et tu vas prendre ton doliprane parce
que sinon compliqué est ce que tu as vu
ça parce qu'on va laisser ta place pour
un jeune
en réalité j'ai pas vu ça parce que
j'étais pas aux urgences quand je suis
allé
quand je suis quand quand il y avait le
comité n'était pas aux urgences
maintenant les médecins sont exprimés à
ce sujet parce qu'il ne pouvait pas
prendre tout le monde donc donc je pense
que je ne peux pas m'exprimer sur le
cheval hier j'ai vu ça je ne les ai pas
vus maintenant le personnel soignant a
dit plusieurs fois qu'il avait été
obligé de faire du tri
site à un moment donné si tu as dit li
et que tu as et que tu as et que tu as
15 personnes tepco il ya un moment donné
ils ont été obligés de choisir les gens
comment ils les ont choisis je ne sais
pas
mais à mon avis à mon avis effectivement
il allait vers le vert le verso du canal
+ de change mais j'en sais rien c'est
vraiment là c'est un avis comme ça mais
il ya beaucoup de soignants qui sont
exprimés sur ce sujet et il me semble il
me semble que c'est un peu ce que j'ai
entendu quand on a demandé aux médecins
de se justifier enfin au personnel
soignant puisque médecin c'est un peu ça
peut largement personnel soignant de de
justifier parce qu'ils ont fait du tri
ils ont été on sait qu'ils ont été
obligés de le faire mais ce qu'ils t'ont
parler de certaines sédation qu'ils ont
donnée parce que je vais pas dire je
vais trivial méchant et un point
d'humour mais il fallait libérer des
lits et il y avait plus de services de
rue avec des places libres et plus d'un
aspirateur et donc non ils n'ont pas eu
de confidences là dessus en revanche je
veux dire pas lié au co vide en revanche
j'ai eu j'ai eu beaucoup de confidences
sur l'euthanasie mais en général mais
pas lié aux qu'ovide je reprécise vient
pallier aux qu'ovide juste j'ai entendu
beaucoup de témoignages de médecins et
personnels soignants etc qui monte
expliqué que que de toute façon quand un
état nazi légal ou pas que quand un
patient était en phase terminale qu'on
ne pouvait plus rien faire pour le
soulager et qu'il n'y avait aucune
chance
qu'il s'en sorte que de toute façon on
m'a fait comprendre que c'était un petit
audible dans nos pires films et
emballages gentiment fait comprendre que
mais de toute façon mais
évidemment
un avis sur notre zee c'est quoi moi je
pense que je pense qu'il faut légaliser
ça je pense que c'est enfin je veux dire
le pour moi c'est même pas un débat je
veux dire la personne
moi j'ai passé j'étais dans les hôpitaux
je les ai vu des gens qui n'allaient pas
bien je suis passé rapidos aux soins
palliatifs je pense que j'ai vu des gens
de ma famille aussi être aux soins
palliatifs j'ai vu des gens de ma
famille dans des états compliqué
c'est scandaleux de laisser souffrir ce
qui est inhumain c'est laisser souffrir
c'est un peu cliché ce que je dis mais
je le dis avec beaucoup de colère parce
que j'ai vu j'ai vu des gens hurler
parce que tu le rates même la morphine
ce que tu veux y a plus rien qui marche
tellement ils ont mal et tu sais qui tu
pourras pas les soigner auquel elle
qu'elle est le quoi
quoi là on est vraiment sur un truc là
on repart soit de la croyance je jouais
doute pas implanté à discuter avec les
équipes de soignants par exemple par des
équipes de soins palliatifs est-ce que
ils ont accès à
des gens pour parler pour se délester de
ce qu'ils portent sur leurs épaules de
souffrance qui voit en face ou est ce
que tu as senti des gens tellement dans
le rush tellement la tête dans le guidon
que lisa baptisa bâti labat le boulou et
et jusque là jusqu'au burn out
c'est une bonne question je je je ne
sais pas s'ils ont un service entre
guillemets de qui est prévu pour eux
pour qu'ils puissent qu'ils puissent
parler c'est une bonne question je sais
pas j'ai pas vu ça en tout cas mais
c'est possible que c'est possible que ça
existe mais je n'en suis pas certain
après le gouvernement adorent mettre en
place des choses du bureau venir des
numéros verts alors donc peut-être
peut-être qu ils ont fait un trou vert
aux aides soignants il mourir à
plaine-haute mais je n'ai pas vu ça ce
que je vois beaucoup c'est l'humour
c'est beaucoup d'humour tu vois tu sens
qu'il ya ils ont cassé enfin moi je
voyais pas de hiérarchie tu vois deux
c'est beaucoup beaucoup d'humour ça
rigole beaucoup ça déconne beaucoup et
ça et ça parle francs tu vois il n'y a
pas de match ça parle français
après je j'ai du mal à croire qu'ils
aient des services de psychiatrie dédié
parce que le service de psychiatrie en
france est la dernière roue du carrosse
c'est là si tu veux trouver un service
où ils n'ont pas de thunes où on leur
donne rien et où on les laisse on les
laisse se démerder tout seul c'est la
psychiatrie là je peux te raconter une
anecdote j'avais fait un service de nuit
avec en urgence psychiatrique et puis la
gentille psychiatre
qui maquille mas qui m'a pris avec elle
toute la nuit à un moment donné elle et
je les laissais pas ce que vous voulez
aller dormir et elle m'a dit hervé
thiard je vais te montrer où je dors
alors on est allé où elle dormait et ça
et ça c'est un truc ça c'est vraiment un
truc que j'ai vu donc on peut pas dire
que c'est pas vrai elle me dirait médias
rien donc donc j'arrive dans un truc
nouveau jeu s'émeut pas de décrire mon
seuil ou une pièce
tout est sale tout est dégueu fin voilà
et avec un lit comme ça et là elle me
dit ben tu vois le dit normalement je
dors là mais regarde et là elle fait ça
je vais pas le faire parce que c'est
quand je sors du cadre en bois elle
donne une petite petite tape comme ça au
lit et comme dans les films le truc
c'est tout le monde
elle y aura donc je dors par terre tout
jeu la dame
regarde
[Rires]
une bonne vingtaine d'années j'ai
pas prendre quarante ans je sais pas je
sais pas exactement trente quarante ans
j'ai pas la vexer je suis rétro de 40
ans était pas était pas si t'es pas et
c'était pas quelqu'un d'âgé quoi qu'est
ce que tu as vu doutre dont par exemple
le service psychiatrique tes visites et
qu'est ce que tu as vu doute qui est ce
que ce qui est passionnant avec la
psychiatrie et c'est pour ça que c'est
scandaleux que ce soit sous financée à
ce point c'est par exemple le j'ai fait
je suis allé avec un autre psychiatre au
service de psychiatrie c'est parce que
des gars dont six en effet en effet plus
j'en ai fait deux et j'en ai fait aussi
une en journée qui était chouette est
hélas lui c'est chouette il m'a vraiment
emmené il m'a vraiment mener partout et
ce qui m'a beaucoup étonné c'est qu'on
l'appelle beaucoup dans les autres
services
ça c'est un truc qu'on sait pas pourquoi
parce que tu as un mec par exemple en
l'occurrence il y avait une dame elle
avait des douleurs attend ce que c'est
un peu vieux faut que je me rappelle un
peu mais bon je vais bottes des anneaux
non non non non bien sûr que non mais je
ne veux pas donner de noms ni rien bien
sûr que non le bon grosso modo je vais
je vais je vais broder un peu l'histoire
mais peu importe puisque c'est le propos
qui est intéressant mais grosso modo
c'est une dame elle avait des douleurs
dans les jambes je sais pas quoi et le
traitement répondait pas et on comprend
et c'est impossible alors elle a des
vrais problèmes physiologiques tu vois
qu'ils ont réussi à traiter les médecins
mais ses douleurs dans les jambes tu
étais pas eu les jambes on va partir là
dessus c'est pareil edward aux mains
d'argent balle ne passe pas tu comprends
pas elles passent pas les douleurs passe
pas ils essayent tout ils sont huit
joueurs passent pas bien la fremm en mal
tu en es tu là généralement quand ils
sont un peu au bout du truc il appelle
le psychiatre pourquoi parce que
psychiatre c'est un médecin qui a une
spécialisation en psychiatrie
et c'est ça qui est absolument dingue
c'est que
là où en france en france ou dans
d'autres pays d'ailleurs un la ou en
tout cas d'une manière générale nous on
a toujours l'impression que le cerveau
c'est quand même dissocier du corps
c'est quelque chose d'un petit peu
aléatoire tu vois on va te dire oui les
douleurs on va avoir la pression que des
douleurs du corps qui sont liées à la
tête c'est pas des vraies douleurs et
des machins c'est pour ça que l'effet
placebo par exemple je suis pas
complètement
et ben dans les hôpitaux tu t'aperçois
qui sont déjà passés un autre step le
stade de la delà de la réalité et la
réalité c'est qu'un psychiatre ils
arrivent ils regardent le dossier il est
complètement capable d'analyser tout
puisque c'est un médecin donc il est
capable d'analyser ce qu'ils ont déjà
fait pourquoi comment
a priori mémé tu vois c'est important ce
que je vais y venir après juste après et
à l'aube 6 4 hélas le psychiatre il va
il va aller parler avec la patiente et
là c'est passionnant parce qu'en fait il
lui parle et tu comprends pas tu
comprends pas toutes les questions qui
lui pose m'en fait pas ce qu'il est en
train de sonder quelque chose et par
exemple cette dame il s'est aperçu qu'en
fait en discutant avec avec avait
quelques en fait elle avait un trouble
un trouble psychiatrique fort et que ce
trouble psychiatrique faisaient que
les douleurs étaient réels dans sa tête
donc dans son corps mais n'était mais
n'était pas n'étaient pas traités par
des médicaments puisque c'était entre
guillemets psychosomatique et il a et en
déverrouillant ce problème de jambes il
a déverrouillé toutes les autres
problèmes parce que du coup en gros si
tu veux le problème de gens ne faisaient
qu on pensait que ce problème là était
lié à un autre problème du coup le
traitement nul autre traitement
fonctionnait pas du tout bref en gros en
trouvons ce trouble psychiatrique on a
pu la guérir pratiquement totalement de
ses douleurs et c'est là où tu te dis
mais comment c'est possible
que personne ne soit au courant de ça et
c'est pour ça aussi que c'est compliqué
trouvé des bombes 6 4 parce qu'en fait
tu t'aperçois à ce moment là qu'il faut
vraiment que quelque il faut vraiment
qu'il soit brillantissime parce qu'un
psychiatre c'est quelqu'un
c'est quelqu'un qui va savoir décelé un
trouble profond
rapidement mais un trouble profond que
le point de quelqu'un qui est un trouble
profond c'est que quand tu le vois tu
sais pas dans quelle phase il
tu le vois une demi heure
tu sais pas dans quel fazila tu peut
confondre un bipolaire et un dépressif
du coup tu peut confondre un bolet avec
un schizophrène tu peut confondre
quelqu'un qui est tu vois quelqu'un qui
est sous drogue avec avec un trophée il
ya un champ des possibles infinie donc
il faut que le mec soit suffisamment
calais en psychiatrie est suffisamment
calais en médecine parce qu'aussi ça
peut être un problème juste d'ordre
physiologique qui crée un trouble un
désordre dans la têtes rasées tu as le
gers est infinie
donc il faut que le mec soit
brillantissime et c'est pour ça qu'il ya
très peu à mon avis de très très bon
psychiatre parce que il faut un panel si
tu veux d'intelligent je parle même pas
de culture d'intelligence d'empathie de
il faut à combo de choses
qui est hallucinant mais par contre
quand le gars est fort moi j'ai eu la
chance de voir un gars qui était
vraiment fort c'est bluffant quoi tu as
tu sais impression de voir un magicien
jeudi son parcours sa formation est ce
qu'il a été formé dans d'autres pays
comme le canada la suisse où ils ont une
approche orientée généralement les
banques' cadre de toute façon vont
toujours le cirque veulent la projetant
le cirque par le cercle c'est une
technique canadienne a tu m'apprends
quelque chose gérer voire
généralement je ne connais pas son
cursus mais il me semble que lui là il a
étudié en france mais met en tout cas ce
qui est certain c'est que tous les tous
les psychiatres tous les bon psychiatre
que j'ai pu croiser et rencontrés sont
toujours curieux des techniques à
l'étranger ça c'est systématique parce
qu'il ya toujours ils sont ses lacets de
la vessie donc il ya toujours des
nouvelles choses et c est surtout en
psychiatrie et ils sont ils sont ils
sont souvent très très curieux de ça moi
je sais que
et il n'y a pas beaucoup d'ego aussi ça
ça j'ai trouvé ça choisir peut-être que
les psychiatres entre la qui m'écoutent
se disent il ya de l'ego d'un bon
service parce que mais en tout cas moi
ce que j'ai pu remarquer c'est que
j'avais il y avait des psychiatres qui
quand moi on m'a fait mal il tente entre
guillemets de troubles y avait aucun
problème à me dire tiens les troubles
obsessionnels va plutôt voir les mecs de
lille ils sont très très fort là dessus
ils vont pouvoir t'aider donc j'allais
voir les mecs doline machin tu vois s'il
n'y avait pas de
monde y va plutôt voir lit plutôt des
études suisse là dessus parce qu'ils
sont un peu en avance sur nous par
rapport à ça et c'est après ça reste des
hommes ce que je veux dire c'est que
encore une fois ça c'est important de le
rappeler c'est que c'est pas parce que
tu es psychiatre que tu sais tout mais
lorsque les médecins que tu sais tout
c'est pas ils peuvent se tromper ils ont
aussi ce sont souvent des gens très
passionné donc il y des gens passionnés
10 des gens entiers souvent des gens
entiers ou peuvent aussi un peu être
têtu tu vas sur certaines choses avoir
du mal à lâcher le morceau parce qu'ils
ont besoin de certitudes pour avancer
pour tenir le coup en patients du
médecin quand ils sont d'études de
médecine joue beaucoup bien sûr c'est
tellement dur mais ça l'est des
croche-pieds pour éviter que août ils se
haïssent échange de cela c'est un bon
coup exactement ça change un peu ils ont
le numéro duberos plus
j'étais coupé est ce que tu veux
terminer je te pose une question est ce
que tu as vu que est ce que tu as été
témoin que le fait de manque de moyens
de financement de toubib conduisait à
une dégradation du soin psychiatrique
qui a mené une psychiatre isation
soviétique c'est bien que ppr bout ils
nous fatiguent pas ce qu'ils veulent
dans le couloir on veut lui donner 4,5
cachetons il dormir un peu arrêtez de me
saoulé est ce que tu as vu des choses
comme ça
je n'ai pas vu à l'hôpital je n'ai pas
vu à l'hôpital ça je les ai vus dans la
vie
comment un médecin généraliste
peut avoir la possibilité de donner des
antidépresseurs et des anxiolytiques
à des gens sans aucune formation le
psychiatre
ça n'a aucun sens ça n'a aucun sens ils
n'ont pas de formation de psy cas des
antidépresseurs il en existe des
milliers à je crois je suis pas sûr
qu'ils aient l'europe préfère tous les
antidépresseurs mais peu importe
moi j'avais un mois j'avais un médecin
dans ma ville il a dit qu'ils filaient
des xanax à tout le monde tu t'étais
cassé la cheville vous allez avoir un
plat pris un peu d'exercice à vous aider
et c'est chiant d'avoir un plâtre
j'ai vu des médecins par exemple quand
quand tu as tu as un problème d'alcool
dont était accro à une molécule qui
s'appelle les benzodiazépines que tu vas
retrouver dans certains sanctionnés tic
etc
j'ai vu quand par exemple quand un
médecin je vais le prendre dans l'autre
sens quand un médecin par exemple va te
tu viens chez un médecin tu lui dis je
suis pas bien j'ai des idées noires ça
va pas et c'est cet oral la première
chose je dis est ce que tu as fait ton
caca ce matin
non mais la première chose qui doit te
demander déjà c est ce qu est ce que tu
prends des est-ce que tu dors bien ce
que tu manges bien est-ce que tu prends
des droits qu'est-ce que tu bois tu sais
c'est la première chose qui doit te
poser comme question
c'est pas de te filer des
antidépresseurs et ça n'a tout seul ils
sont pas tous comme ça ils ne font pas
tout ça mais il ya quand même énormément
de gens mais je chante je vends france
pour la consommation des médicaments des
médicaments et des entier pleure j'ai
pas vérifié les chiffres récemment mais
mais moi je trouve personnellement je
pense que les gens qui nous regardent je
pense que la majorité des gens derrière
leur écran qui prennent les
anxiolytiques ou des antidépresseurs ou
toute forme de médicaments de ce style
je suis pratiquement sûr que la majorité
sont des gens qui ont été prescrits par
leur médecin généraliste
c'est pas un jugement je leur fais je
comprends qu'ils aient confiance je
dirais peut-être nécessaire
je me fais c'est à plein mais je
comprends ton raisonnement mais
peut-être que c'est nécessaire mais dans
ce cas là qui rebascule ça sur
l'applicatif situe à pour moi pardon je
suis peut-être un peu moi je trouve ça
dingue quand j'ai vu le travail des pics
à quand je les études qu'ils font quand
je vois ce que la coupe la complexité de
précieuses antidépresseurs de voir qu'en
fait c'est tandis presseur faut surtout
pas boire avait faut surtout pas faire
s'il faut surtout pas faire ça faut pas
le mélanger avec sa faux pas faire s'il
faut pas faire ça je lisais alors les
benzodiazépines par exemple quand on
quand un mec boit de l'alcool et à des
problèmes d'alcool ne faut pas lui filer
de benzodiazépines j'ai jamais jamais de
ma vie j'ai eu des gens qui ont eu des
problèmes d'alcool autour de moi moi
j'en ai eu beaucoup moi par exemple
quand j'ai dit que j'avais des problèmes
d'alcool mais médecins généralistes me
proposait du glas des pinceaux diaz
epide donc c'est comme c'est exactement
comme si je te donne la même chose mais
sauf que le de le donner en litige
talents cachés ça n'a aucun sens moi
j'ai parlé que des médecins généralistes
mais vous savez que quand on boit de
l'alcool font pas pression de
benzodiazépines pour nous donc ce que je
veux dire c'est que
peut-être c'est nécessaire peut-être
c'est nécessaire mais dans ce cas là
c'est ca des gens qui ont fait des
études spécifiques c'est à eux de le
dire je dis pas que les psychiatres ont
pas parfois aussi la main lourde sur les
cachets je pense que de toute façon de
manière générale il ya un problème avec
ça je faisais chier avec les cachets
avec les cachets de manière générale
déjà je trouve que c'est pour moi les
médecins généralistes ne devrait pas
pouvoir prescrire ce type de ce type de
médicamentation ça je reste convaincu de
ça j'ai vu autour de moi des dizaines et
des dizaines et des dizaines de
personnes retrouvées se retrouve avec
des anxiolytiques et des machins hyper
addictif prescrits par des généralistes
sans raison valable j'en ai trop vu donc
si tu as un vrai problème tu as des
psychiatres sont à disposition tu peux
aller les voir c'est à eux de prescrire
et même si je trouve encore une fois
qu'ils prescrivent trop et de manière
générale je trouve qu'on ne pose pas les
bonnes questions aux gens pourquoi
pourquoi qui est ce que tu manges bien
est-ce que tu bois bien est-ce que tu
dors bien est ce que tu fais du sport
est ce que tu es une relation tu veux
que je lui dis ce que tu fais quand même
est-ce que tu as des relations sexuelles
est-ce que tu as une vie épanouie ça
paraît un discours très bateau mais est
bon on n'a pas encore parlé de mes
expériences mais je peux le dire parce
que je buvais 6 litres de rosé par jour
j'ai fait une tentative de suicide
ce sont ces choses là c'était du bout
non je te fais de la merde du rosé
dégueulasse enfin du bourg osé mais bon
c'est à cette boue rosé bon tu vois déjà
quand je dis bon rosé y en a plein dit
mais tu vois ce que je veux dire c'est
que les choses qui m'ont sauvé au delà
de en plus de plein de choses c'est en
tout cas les choses qui maintiennent la
en ce moment bien sans médicaments ce
sont ces choses là bien manger bien
dormir faire du sport boire de l'eau et
essayer de s'épanouir tu vois
là demain je vais voir un médecin en
deux secondes jeudi j'avais des
problèmes d'alcool j'ai fait deux
tentatives machin vous voulez quoi comme
comme c'est sûr j'ouvre une parenthèse
encore et à côté de ça est ce que tu as
vu un phénomène énergie de chahat en
couches de vie qu'ils disent voilà tu
vas boire un petit jus de
fruits mélangés des petites herbes ça va
te faire repousser les doigts ou décorer
comme ça t'en faire repousser les doigts
là on est sur un halloween aurait dû
level je vais dire qu'il y en a qui sont
un petit peu zinzin gants après après je
pense que ça c'est plus que tu as vu et
ce phénomène en fait est immergé des
pseudos charlatans de la médecine
je pense que c'est plutôt internet
honnêtement je pense que c'est plutôt
internet il ya deux phénomènes mais
internet déjà nous a permis quand même
d'avoir un paquet de charlatans dans à
peu près tous les domaines où je les
trouvais les trophées il ya quand même
pas beaucoup de domaines dans lesquels
on trouve pas de charlatans grâce à
internet donc c'est quand même c'est
quand même quand même il est concentré
bien oui mais alors après tu sais mais
c'est le problème c'est qu'on n'est
encore sûr le même truc c'est que des
codecs ça relève du domaine de la
croyance ça devient compliqué tu as des
que dès que mais après avoir d'écho 2001
tu parle d'économie entre autres non
mais tu as et je veux dire c'est que des
carrés sur des gens qui te disent je
vais vous expliquer comment comment
comment aller mieux bon tout de suite
sans avoir même une petite question se
pose que parce que parce qu est-ce que
déjà toi tu vas bien nous mais après
c'est comme les gens qui explique
comment devenir riches et c'est je crois
pas que ce soit du
il est évident il est évident qu'à
partir du moment où les gens décident de
faire un peu plus attention à eux il est
évident que va fleurir derrière ça des
centaines de mecs qui vont expliquer
comment elle est mieux puisque il ya une
demande il ya une offre alors dans cette
offre évidemment il ya à boire et à
manger sas et puis surtout sur tous ces
trucs très très bon c'est pas palpable
tu vois je vais t'aider aller mieux bon
tu vois ses traits
c'est vrai non mais mais après je pense
que
tu vois moi ce mot souvent quand on me
demande comment je m'en suis sortie je
dis aux gens dit aux gens bois bien dors
bien mange bien machin levrat web et
c'est pour me dire ça et puis qu'est ce
que tu veux parce que toi ce que tu veut
c'est garder la même vie avoir une date
d'une boîte de cachet tu peux pas si tu
veux aller mieux il faut changer des
habitudes parce que comme encore si on
revient sur les troubles et les pensées
par on sait que l'alcool par exemple été
est un dépresseur donc c'est quelque
chose qui te rend dépressif
si le gars il dort pas bien qui boit de
l'alcool mais je parle même pas d'un
alcoolique comme moi comme moi j'ai pu
l'être mais juste quelqu'un qui dit qui
boit trop la semaine trois cas traces
dans la semaine il dort pas bien
mach'allah il pouffe de la merde il se
fait une boîte de raviolis en rentrant
le midi mange pas il comprend pas
pourquoi il grossit parce qu'il ouvre
une boîte de raviolis le soin donc tu
vois donc le garder comme ça il va chez
le médecin dit tu crois vraiment que ce
médecin va lui dire est ce qu'on va ce
qu'on va faire c'est que vous allez
commencer à avoir correctement arrêter
de manger salle à une fois sur deux je
dis pas que tous les généralistes font
ça heureusement il y en a des bons comme
dans tous les domaines mais une fois sur
deux tueurs à giresse qui va dire
écoutez on va vous prescrit un petit peu
le lexomil déjà pour vous aider à dormir
prenez-ça machin vous avez l'angoissé à
écouter un petit un petit peu de xanax
vous en prenez un 2000 matin jeu et
c'est parti mais le mec tu peux lui
filer quatre tonnes de xanax s'il dort
pas qui se met des murs en permanence
qu'il est fatigué que son boulot ne lui
plaît pas et qu'il vous fait une boîte
de raviolis soir il va continuer d'aller
mal situés en fait c'est traiter
d'ailleurs compris la base le milieu
socioculturel pour ensuite d'abord
savoir comment les gens vivent et voir
ce qui reste comme problème alors
maintenant on va élargir le sujet
quand tu vois notre société qui part en
sucette économiquement parlant
énergétiquement parlant socialement
parlant qui part en sucette à peu près
partout
est-ce que les to become a été en
immersion et ont dit non et le dernier
rempart face à cette mondialisation qui
détruit les gens est-ce qu il ya ce
raisonnement
aberrant les toubibs ils disent nous
sommes les victimes de ce système ils
n'ont pas l'impression d'être un rempart
ils ont l'impression d'avoir déjà été
broyés avaler recracher etc non les
médecins ils sont les mais les médecins
tu sais à partir du moment déjà où tu
goûtes où tu mets à la tête des chu tu
mets des gens qui n'y connaissent rien
la médecine tu mets délicieux mets des
gestionnaires non mais ça c'est ça c'est
ça c'est le truc le plus génial de cette
planète est formidable parce que je dis
pas que c'est une personne a je pense
c'est un système tu vois qui c'est un
qui sait qui c'est qui s'est mis cette
manière mais ça c'est ça c'est vraiment
l'idée de génie si tu veux être sûr que
ton hôpital perd pas trop tu mets un mec
qui n'y connait rien la médecine parce
que du coup tu as plein de services dans
les hôpitaux donc je peux à terre dire
n'importe quoi jean vendre des trucs
talent radiologue il faut une nouvelle
machine parce que pour traiter tel type
de machin je sais pas quoi il faut telle
machine jour là tu mets un mec qui
connaît un peu la médecine un peu
l'image qu'on sauzet moi j'étais
convaincu que que ces machins là était
tenue par des vieux médecin c'est comme
dans les films le mec a tout vu qu a
tout connu café tous les services
qu'elle une empathie incroyable une
grosse voiture qui est hyper rassurant
même quand il annonce que tu vas mourir
tu es content tellement il est
charismatique
et est en fait et en fait non en fait
ils tombent ya un mec qui a fait une
école dans cette école on n'apprend pas
la médecine on t'apprend à compter en
tablant à faire des tableaux excel donc
à tous pas tous dans les chu en tout cas
c'est maintenant donc les chu c'est pas
des anciens médecins après ça ça arrive
de temps en temps encore heureusement
enfin a priori je pense qu'on va plus
vers avoir que des gestionnaires que un
retour arrière on allait reprendre des
médecins j'ai aussi on a commencé à
mettre des gestionnaires la tête des chu
c'est pas pour ce n'est pas pour faire
marche arrière je pense donc je pense
qu'en plus là dessus mais en fait c'est
brillant parce que
tu as un mec il comprend pas de quoi tu
lui parles c'est que tu arrives avec ton
problème de radiologie ou ton problème
de pédiatrie où ton problème de chez pas
quoi il ne sais pas de quoi tu lui
parles il n'y a aucune notion serre que
c'est quand même c'est quand même génial
serre que tu arrives tu dis ouais mais
moi ce que je vois dans mon service mais
je ne sais pas de quoi tu me parles je
ne comprends pas ce que tu me dis je n'y
connais rien la médecine moi ce que je
vois c'est combien ça coûte alors ne se
rendent pas à la case et rouge tu
rentres tu sais quand même c'est quand
même fou est ce que tu as vu cette
conférence de presse avant que vit doubs
juste autour du cou vide où tu avais des
directeurs de service et les directrices
de services débarqué en disant où là on
nous demande du rendement c'est une
clientèle congères on demande un au nom
de la rentabilité
expliqué qu'il pouvait pas traiter les
patients comme ça chez les patients
s'étaient pas des clients c'était des
passions mais en fait c'est le problème
d'avoir d'avoir confondu
c'est le problème d'avoir c'est un ami
d'alors qui qui qui travaillent dans la
santé qui m'a dit ça c'est con on a
confondu comment il m'a 17 heures on a
confondu
demandes et besoins
d'affaires contre est comme si c'était
une demande tu vas serre qu'est ce qu'on
a en demandent mais c'est pas des
demandes c'est les besoins donc c'est
cesser complètement différent parce que
déjà la demande tu peux la quantifier
sans faire de mal ça dépend sur quel
sujet mais enfin si on parle d'une
demande de l'iphone mais ça va pas faire
beaucoup de mal si tu dis on va pas
répondre à toutes les demandes par un
drame tu vois alors que t'es foutu pose
des questions ouais alors que j'ai un
cancer s'est pas c'est pas une faudrait
des sources pas une demande c'est un
besoin tu vois donc ils ont essayé avec
la t2a
alors le thé désosser le sait la
tarification à l'acte j'avais discuté
avec des gens je discute avec des gens
qui ont eu ce qu'ils ont fait partie des
gens qui ont mis en place la t2a alors
pour que les gens comprennent bien en
gros je vais être un peu de manière
générale je suis un peu large dans mes
réponses je le précise parce qu'internet
adore prendre toute les petits détails
puis je suis obligé de faire un peu
large j'ai conscience que je suis pas
totalement exact dans tout mais enfin
c'est pour ces pour faire un truc un peu
large gagner du temps en gros pas du
temps ouais mais bon quand même c'est
toujours un peu compliqué d'aller dans
tous les détails de tous parce que c'est
tellement complexe mais grosso modo
avant on va dire que les gens les
hôpitaux facturent est au nombre de
jours que le patient restait dans un lit
grosso modo ce que ça donc il restait
trois jours facturés 3 je restais deux
jours cageots et ainsi de suite donc on
a remarqué qu'ils auraient tendance à
garder un peu plus les gens parce que je
certainement qu'ils avaient besoin de
plus d'argent dans leurs oeufs dans
leurs hôpitaux et qu'il fallait faire
entrer les cases dans les cases donc
c'était déjà le même problème parce que
le médecin lui tu reste quatre jours en
tout cas le médecin dans le public que
tu reste quatre jours aux 6 jours et pas
payer plus donc de toutes façons c'était
pas un acte malveillant mais il avait
tendance à va se rendre compte que les
gens restés un peu trop longtemps donc
du coup ça coûtait trop d'argent donc
ils ont dit on va faire autrement et ils
ont mis en place la t2a et ça c'est
intéressant parce que c'est un des gars
qui a mis en place la t2a qui m'a
expliqué sa on était vraiment au départ
on avait vraiment une volonté de faire
quelque chose de positif on n'était pas
sur un truc de rentabilité presque
imaginer ce qu'ils disent la vérité j'en
sais un peu importe et donc ils ont mis
en place la t2a donc la t2a c'est ben
maintenant on va pas on va pas on va pas
vous allez pas facturé nombre de gens le
nombre de journées pour lequel le
patient reste on va facturer les actes
que vous lui faites pourquoi parce que
tu gardes avec quatre jours tu lui a pas
fait d'actes donc pourquoi tu la gardes
et quatre jours donc maintenant vous
allez devoir justifier nombre de jours
qui restent vous allez faire des actes
et nous ce qu'on va payer ce sont les
actes donc maintenant mais qu'est ce que
tu vois tu vois une multiplication des
actes et puis des gens qui restent de
moins en moins longtemps dans les lits
parce que le problème de fond le
problème de fond c'est le manque
d'argent des hôpitaux dont tu peux
mettre le système que tu veux les mecs
ils vont toujours essayé de te faire
rentrer des ronds dans des carrés donc
tu peux mettre n'importe quel système ça
arrivera toujours aux mêmes au même
point parce que le problème de base
c'est qu'il n'y a pas assez d'argent
dans les hôpitaux et est donc à ce mec
il dit oui bon on se rend compte
maintenant détails de la t2a machin
machin machin on pensait faire bien mais
à aucun moment il se dit mais pourquoi
le mec pour pourquoi les hôpitaux sont
obligée d'allonger s'il gagne ce single
a besoin d'être là deux jours pourquoi
pourquoi pourquoi ils disent qu'il va
rester trois ou quatre jours faut que
vous vous posez action puisqu'il est pas
payer plus lui donc si le pourquoi il le
fait plutôt que deux et on va trouver un
autre système parce qu'ils ne font pas
bien non mais la question c'est pourquoi
il ne fait pas bien tu vois donc c'est
donc c'est toujours comme ça tu vois
donc donc la t2a a été
renforcé ça parce que du coup maintenant
ils sont mis à chronométrer les patients
les machins fois les vitres et puis et
puis en plus de ça c'est de moins en
moins financer la population vieillit
augmente donc si tu veux c'est un
effondrement par les deux sens pire
venait d'arriver à un point de rupture
qui était avant le covin parce qu'avant
le covin 7 on est déjà un point de
rupture takan des soignants qui font des
grèves de la faim des grèves de la faim
on leur a dit a pas d'argent y'a rien on
n'a pas de tune on peut rien faire
l'argent ne lui a pas d'argent magic n'a
pas on peut rien faire avec on peut rien
vous donner à vous êtes sur un mois dans
la rue et tous les machins ou fermer les
urgences ils ont fait des trucs toujours
des grèves de la faim et on voit la crs
on n'a pas d'argent il va pas lâcher
quoi kovy dans les boxes 300 milliards
ils sont fait prendre la main dans le
sac quand tu vois des soignants est
obligé de se mettre d des chasubles on
sacs poubelles et sacs poubelles parce
qu'ils avaient plus de bizarre ils
n'avaient pas assez d'argent pour donner
des sur blanc et puis ma est ce que
redoutaient les basques qui racontaient
des billevesées avec l'intermédiaire du
porte-parole du gouvernement aux
histoires histoires de mes engagé entre
deux ou pour éviter de se faire taper
dessus trop sur les doigts mais en
réalité ce qui a énervé les soignants
est ce que je comprends totalement s'est
traitée comme de l'avenir oui mais
c'était surtout au début au tout début
au tout début il ya eu un petit
mouvement des soignants qui disait avec
arrive à vous vous rendez compte
maintenant que c'est la merde ce que je
comprends pas ce que ça coûte tout à
coup tout le monde s'est soucié du
personnel de santé en les pauvres aux
infirmiers d'accord donc avant je me
faisais insulter en salles d'attentes et
maintenant vous applaudissez au
peut-être n'est-ce pas que je suis je
suis aéro donc je comprends ça parce que
parce que moi j'étais avec eux avant
donc je comprends très bien que le truc
ah oui et d'accord maintenant c'est pas
et puis après comme ce sont
fondamentalement encore une fois des
gens les gens bien les gens empathique
des gens des gens qui aiment l'humain
ils se sont plus trop se soucier sap ils
ont juste essayé de faire le mieux
qu'ils pouvaient avec avec ce qu'ils
avaient et après ils se sont
effectivement aussi un peu servi de ça
pour essayer de mettre en lumière sa aux
yeux du gouvernement gouvernement qui
donc n'a absolument rien fait de plus à
l'heure actuelle et alors ils ont fait
encore mieux là je me suis dit là bas
ils continuent de fermer au fur et à
mesure au fur et à mesure et alors le
truc alors le truc le truc formidable ce
que j'étais sur le site je sais plus sur
ce site mais c'est un site officiel du
gouvernement parce que je me suis fait
une petite mise à jour tu sais comme
j'étais en vacances ça bon quand je
reviens je rappelle un peu les gens est
ce qu'il ya des nouveaux trucs des trucs
que j'ai loupé parce que je suis comme
tout le monde tu en entends je me
j'arrête un peu de regarder des trucs et
je t'ai soit aussi du gouvernement ira
c'est formidable parce que il parle
d'eux j'ai trouvé ça génial il parle de
la crise
il parle de la crise de l'hôpital du
haut que vides c'est à dire que ils sont
maître hervé [__] mais moi je suis un
soignant je dis ça chez melick son
pardon des
méchants une personne parce que
franchement les mecs ils font décrypte
la faim dans la rue avant le colis dit
ça fait 15 ans qu'on n'a plus d'argent
c'est horrible en gros c'est ça ça fait
20 ans qu'on donne de moins en moins aux
hôpitaux donc ça fait vingt ans que ça
s'effondre comme ça le plus en plus et
là maintenant il te donne rien pendant
le vide ils payent les sociétés ils
payent les gens
ce qui était très bien je vais pas
cracher dessus la société a reçu des
aides qu'est-ce qu'ils ont donnée aux
hôpitaux sur le long terme un rien du
tout ils ont augmenté un petit peu les
gens ce que j'étais tout à l'heure ce
qui est toujours pas suffisant parce que
ça fait toujours de les personnes et
moins ne payez rien sur le long terme
aucun engagement sur le long terme pas
de lit sont promus délit on verra s'ils
le font de façon tu pourras jamais
compté même l'élite façon tu les lycées
un comptable parce que toute façon tu
regarde les graphiques oui là il ya
délit deux jours et aller lits de
psychiatrie il ya les lits de machado
toute façon les chiffres tu peux tu vois
juste que ça baisse mais ils trouveront
toujours un exemple pour te dira mais
regardez là on a ouvert quatre cents
lits mais tu sais si ça se trouve c'est
quatre semaines tu sais tu sais même pas
te sens tu comprends rien parce que
après ils vont te les chiffres toute
façon ils font ce qu'ils veulent tu fais
ce que tu veux avec les chiffres c'est
des échelles tellement importante que tu
ne peux pas tu ne peux pas tu ne peut
pas calculer
donc comme
la gestion du coc vide
comment t'as vu truc partir comme on a
vécu trop finement comment tu as vécu le
la position de la porte parolat du
gouvernement
ces vases ndiaye ouais bah c'est moi
c'est moi si vous tenez à chaque fois
qu'elle prenait la parole à un sketch à
s'était elle s'était elle c'est m haies
en je te jure journée
j'ai beaucoup d'affection ce qu'elle m'a
tellement fait ces dérives elle m'a
tellement fait rire mais sincèrement
elle me faisait vraiment rire que du
coup bah quand on quand on l'a attaqué
dans mon jeu de société pour la fage de
société sur le souk au vide ce cas
comment il s'appelle état d'urgence où
on a voulu et justement tu vois c'est
exactement pour ça qu'on a fait ce jeu
c'est parce que on voulait cristallisé
tout ce qui s'était passé pendant le
coït parce que tu sais les hommes
politiques c'est pour ça c'est les
hommes politiques c'est incroyable ce
qu'ils en font tellement il ya tellement
en fait tout le temps tu sécheresse a
déjà remarqué ça dans les médias mais en
fait quelqu'un qui vient quelqu'un qui
vient rarement dans les médias on peut
détruire sa carrière assez facilement tu
vois là moi imaginons on voit pas tout
le temps tu vois je suis assez discret
jeune temps en temps là il ya un mec qui
va reprendre une phrase dans cette
interview il va la prendre et c est ça
va être très facile de reprendre de
déformer puis d'essayer de m'attaquer et
peut-être même d'arriver vraiment à me
faire du mal durant déformant en prenant
un truc dont je ne sais pas
alors que quelqu'un qui est installée
qui a accès aux médias en permanence il
te fait oublier ça sert que citer tous
les jours en télé c'est fini tu vois tu
le tonton petit bad buzz ton tam tam à
l'adresse son truc il est rattrapé les
broyer ses remplacées par de nouvelles
images et au fur et à mesure bas ça y
est on a oublié tu vois et la politique
c'est ça et c'est pour ça qu'on a voulu
faire ce jeu ce jeu on a pris toutes les
deux un gris tous les trucs qu'on a
trouvé les plus où ce qui était fait
pendant le coc vie des enseignants on va
en faire un jeu de société ça ça va
amuser les gens savaient faire marrer
tout ça on a fait un truc humoristique
mais surtout qu'on n'oublie pas quoi
qu'on n'oublie pas et là j'ai le coc
vite ça a été cette informatique m'ont
alors après là il ya quelque chose qui
est un peu un peu personnel et un peu
joué à combien est à ton jeu parce que
tu sais la valeur il risque d'y avoir
des coupures d'électricité et donc j'ai
rappelé internet puis de boxe plus de
téléphones portables a cédé mais qu'ils
anticipent soif d'ailleurs d'ailleurs on
leur passer un petit message ce que je
sois qui nous écoutent appelé les
libanais en ce moment ils vont vous
donner des conseils de résilience et
vous expliquer quand il ya plus
d'électricité que la chaîne du froid cas
c'est que les gens ils osent plus mangé
dans le restaurant parce que la chaîne
du froid ils peuvent tomber malades que
les antennes 2g et c'est bon quand il a
pris quoi on va y appuie gsm en fait je
l'invite du coup parce que si on peut
jouer à combien at-on jeu le jean se
jouer à 6
ans dans le foot u d'ailleurs on peut
jouer aussi tout seul alors le jour va
être très honnête on va rendre à césar
ce qui appartient à césar cet effet dans
mon associé qui s'appelle michael yon
que tu que tu connais bien aussi qui est
à passer le bonjour il passe le bonjour
qu'elle a passionné des jeux de société
il voulait déjà faire un jeu de société
sur fond de caisse à beyrouth car moi ça
me passionne pas les jeux société à la
battue ou support puis voulait faire un
jeu de société avec vente de pièces à
beyrouth il a il avait fait des cartes
plastifiées pour me faire un pilote
d'une société pour essayer de convaincre
m'intéressait lycée qui sait que c'est
pas mon truc et puis et puis où ses
parents l'avaient pas fait bon et puis
quand il est le co vide on s'est dit ah
comment on va parler de ça parce que
donc j'ai rallongé du coup un peu le
spectacle pour quand même traité passe
comme puisque des géniales avec le co
vite c'est que ça consolide énormément
le propos de mon spectacle puisque moi
dans le spectacle est en train de dire
si un jour il ya un truc qui nous tombe
sur la gueule on va voir que le système
ne tient pas kiki qui est donc ce donc
ça vachement
alors quand tu vois le spectacle la
réponse a toujours été claire etc comme
ça parce que j'ai juste eu à rajouter
des petites pièces à droite à gauche tu
vois et donc mika elle me dit hélas
quand il est arrivé mi cab on était en
plein confinement on avait tous très
peur bon je vais épargné aux gens le
truc j'ai eu peur de perdre les boîtes
j'ai eu peur de tout perdre j'ai eu peur
qu'on rejoue jamais bon bah on va pas
rentrer sur mes angoisses et ce moment
puis là ça va donc on va leur épargner
cette partie là mais mika me dit mais
kaka bien conscience qu'il faut aussi
m'occuper pourquoi que deviennent fous
j'ai envie de tuer les gens et tout ça
pourquoi on n'aurait pas le voir comment
ce qui est triste
c'est 10 de l'eau du sommet et savoir
prévient xanax
et donc il dit c'est très bien qu'on
reprenne cette idée du jeu de société
tout ça j'ai un watch a bonne idée et
donc du coup on a on a on a retravaillé
sur ce jeu alors le truc c'est que mika
comme c'est un vrai passionné de société
mais quand je suis un vrai passionné
c'est pas le monopoly tu vois c'est un
mec tu lui parles du monopoly tu fais
pardon c'est ce genre de mec on est sur
un mec c'est les jeux
c'est le livre dont vous êtes le héros
on est c'est un gars il à 260 jeux de
société chez lui d'accord c'est un
malade des jeux de société et le
problème c'est qu'il a beaucoup plus de
jeux de société que d'amis qui ont envie
de jouer au jeu de société parce que
c'est pas non plus un truc tu vois c'est
pas un gentil remettre quand même
j'arrête parce qu'on les a enfermés chez
eux que ce qui brille mais à un moment
donné c'est quand même pas mais mickaël
organise des soirées dès samedi soir
dont on va faire du jeu de société bon
il a trois personnes c'est toujours les
mêmes c'est des mêmes personnes trouvera
pas plus il a épuisé les villes de
france ils sont trois à vouloir faire
dès samedi
du coup
il voulait qu'on fasse un jeu à la fois
il voulait pas que faire un truc trop
basique tu vois pas ce qu'il s'est dit
oui la communauté des jeux de société je
veux pas qu'elle se moque de moi parce
que lui il est là dedans il vole salon
du jeu de société il parle avec des
concepteurs et donc il a fait un jeu
mais j'ai dit oui mais attention faut
quand même pas que ce faut quand même
que les mecs comme moi qui sont pas des
oufs de jeux de société s'amuse quand
même donc on a fait un truc un peu entre
les deux c'est à dire que c'est un vrai
chouettes jeux de société il ya de la
stratégie un peu de hasard mais c'est
très bien dosé faut se prendre un tout
petit peu la tête au début pour capter
les règlements deux parties ça y est tu
as compris et en même temps on a on a
travaillé sur les cartes donc c'est des
dessins humoristiques qui représente
toutes les toutes les dingueries qu'on a
pu voir un gouvernement j'ai réfléchi à
des exemples mais tu sais quoi y'en a
tellement chaud qu'il ya 4 un kart donc
et alors ce qui est marrant avec cette
sorte donc on sort le jeu de société
alors on le fabrique tout ça on le
balance en magasin etc ils sortent le
pass sanitaire mais nous les boîtes
elles étaient fabriquées et où on
n'avait pas traité de cassani terre de
nantua
les gens jouent et déjà les gens nous
dit rien vous n'avez pas traiter dupas
sanitaire vous avez fait un refus
d'obstacle pour que vous n'avez pas
traiter du patois d'iter voulez pas vous
engager tu vois pas ce que le problème
d'être engagée c'est que du coup tout le
monde pas tant que ça et dès que tu
parles pas juste pour comme s'y était
engagé tu as perdu tu es kourita change
les faits plus personne maintenant
voiture la société a broyé à deux donc
faire avec ce truc de passer donc du
coup je dis c'est qu'on va faire une
extension passe sanitaire donc du coup
on a retravaillé on a retravaillé sur de
nouvelles cartes mais il faut pas que ce
parce que faut pas que les gens aient
l'impression aussi que tu que tu as
essayé de le reprendre 5 euros de plus
tu vois pas ce que c'est ça aussi
prendre part ou vous avez fait une
extension pour ne reprendre 5 euros
parce que tu as il faut tout repenser
pourquoi quand le jeu pas cher 19 euros
je crois autant je suis pas sûr
j'ai un doute 14
oui c'est sûr aux usa il ait bahi
lessard est un peu cher parce que bon
c'est le pack a dîné tous et très cher
si je voudrais qu'elle cher à fabriquer
en réalité et le prix du bouquet mais
oui mais nous on essaie toujours de
faire des prix très bas tu sais bien moi
mes places de spectacle c'est 40 45
euros le dvd il est à moins de 10 euros
donc en tout cas je sais plus exactement
à combien est la boîte de jeu mais en
tout cas on est on est beaucoup moins
cher que la plupart des jeux vous
trouverez en a pour tout ça c'est
certain par contre parce qu'on essaye
toujours en grattant un peu tout partout
et en grattant aussi sur notre marge
voilà mais on en a on en a vendu
beaucoup genre qu'on en a vendu 15 ou 20
mille tu vas donc ça a vraiment bien
marché les gens sont beaucoup amusés que
ces deux sociétés et on a créé le petit
pas sanitaires et donc on a rajouté une
règle dans le passé ni terre ça c'est
pas simplement des cartons plus
rigolotes sur le passe à lithaire on a
ajouté une règle de jeu donc en fait
c'est génial parce qu'on a reproduit un
peu ce que tu vivais dans la vie se
taire si tu avais pas trop il n'avait
pas tant de passe en fait tu avais dans
tes cartes que tu tires tu as des
possibilités de vacciner et si tu les
prends pas elle va au bout d'un moment
tu attends une carte qui sort et on te
dit montrez vos pass sanitaires et si tu
l'as pas eh ben tu es exclu du jeu tu
dois porter à ma studette éloigné de la
table et où es tu dois payer pour jouer
sinon tu ne joues pas tu en as fait des
trucs un petit peu comme ça un petit peu
rigolo et ça avait beaucoup beaucoup
amusé des gens et dans ce jeu là s creed
amis genre l'extension
tu travailles dans les médias t
politique tu vas te faire des bambins
pendant le confinement ou des à la barre
de tout le monde tu sais comment ils
s'appellent les dîners de monsieur
chalencon ah oui on a mais on a traité
tout ça va dans les cartons à traiter
tout ça on a très franchement je crois
pas il n'y a pas beaucoup de sujets il
n'y a pas beaucoup de sujets qu'on n'a
pas traité parce qu'en plus tu sais on
j'ai la chance maintenant d'avoir une
belle équipe autour de moi avec des gens
de tout âge de tout milieu de tout
horizon des gens qu'on fait des études
d'autres non enfin c'est chez moi c'est
c'est l'arche de noé comprend tous les
gens qui ont qui ont juste il arrive et
dit je suis père passionné tu vois tu
peux venir chez nous c'est pas un appel
à l'offre on recrute pas 15 dingue
demain je suis partie de salaire mais
est du coup en fait mon travail beaucoup
comme ça c'est à dire contrat est de
notre côté et après généralement partage
vraiment et que tout le monde quoi ça
qu'on va dans les bureaux tout le monde
et l'état ça te fait rire qu'est ce qui
t'a choqué et je me rappelle qu'on a un
groupe du bureau du ce et on se raconte
des conneries et tout ça et on avait dit
qu'elles sont tous les trucs qui vous
ont qui vous ont marqué le plus
revenons à l'expérience coleader
alors ben alors le commandement alors il
ya 2 il ya deux expériences il
yal'expérience encore une fois trois
pays
ouais il a attrapé mais je les suis en
allant à l'aéroport pour partir en
vacances j'étais content c'est pas parti
là bas non
non surtout que je parte en thaïlande on
est arrivé là bas avec le co vie de
nature sortait du ressortait vingt ans
après donc non non je suis pas parti
ballon du coup j'ai pas partie la seule
touche gothique ouais si j'étais vaccine
hypoxie lit alors le vaccin le vaccin
c'est un c1 c'est un truc
je ne botte pas en touche mais c'est une
partie
très important dans le spectacle parce
que c'est un truc sur lequel j'ai fait
j'ai fait des recherches et je sors des
vrais trucs sur le vaccin dans le
spectacle est donc
je ne m'exprime pas sur le vaccin parce
que sinon je spoile cette partie du
spectacle et je veux pas là spoiler
parce que je veux que les gens vivent à
vivre le truc avec moi sur scène après
toute façon ce sera diffusée à télé et
puis ça va ça sortira mémé et même quand
les journalistes viennent voir le
spectacle jordi éviter de parler de
cette partie de vaccins et pour
l'instant ils ont tous joué le jeu parce
que parce que je fais des jeux fait les
voilà je fais des vraies révélations et
ses voix je veux que ce soit un truc qui
reste pour l'instant dans le spectacle
d'autres trucs traitements alternatifs
tu parles de c'est un traitement
alternatif est ce que tu parles des
masques tu parles de alors j'ai pas pu
m'empêcher de faire j'ai pas pu
m'empêcher de faire évidemment un état
des lieux général de ce qu'on a de ce
qu'on a vécu pendant le coït j'attaque
un peu j'attaque beaucoup de trucs un
j'attaque je regrette le comportement de
la presse qui pour moi a été
alors encore une fois ce n'est pas tout
la presse c'est la même chose ce que
j'aime pas ça j'aime pas quand les gens
font dire j'ai arrêté donc je précise
toujours c'est pas tout la presse enfin
beaucoup beaucoup quand même j'ai pas
beaucoup d'exemples de gens qui n'ont
pas fait de cette
de ce comptage
abominable qu'on a vécu tous les jours
compter les morts comptés l'erea à
compter les clusters et ont compté on
comptait quand on n'a pas de chiffres
c'est pas grave on reprend les anciens
qu'elle voit que ça va être pire après
ils n'ont pas arrêté de nous assassiner
la tête en permanence avec j'ai vécu ça
avec une grande violence c'est à dire
que
ça m'a mis en colère ça m'a mise en
dépression
et après ça m'angoisse et c'est à dire
que ce qui est terrible c'est que moi
qui étudie tous ces trucs depuis des
dettes des années tu vois de la presse
les pièges dans lesquels il faut pas
tomber cet art etc je me suis vu et
c'est mes amis qui m'ont dit mes mecs
pas toi je me suis vu parce que le
problème c'est que
moi je n'attendais que ça réouvre pour
pouvoir travailler payer les employés
faire vivre les boîtes reprendre la
tournée parce qu'il faut savoir quand
même que donc moi on ouvre anesthésie
générale on vend 100 mille billets avant
que ça démarre avant que la promo ne
démarre donc j'avais un an de tournée
d'avant ce au moment où on doit y aller
on n'y va pas
et donc moi à chaque fois je décale les
dates et je me dis ma tournée est morte
mais quand une tournée est morte c'est
pas c'est pas c'est pas si moi ta vie
qu'on tue ses cinq ans parce que moi
j'ai deux ans d'études et trois ans
tourner ses cinq ans si je perds cinq
ans de ma vie je perds cinq ans de ma
vie de ce que j'aime faire le plus au
monde je te parle même pas les
conséquences sur les sociétés sur ma vie
sur reims et c'est pas un petit truc tu
vois
et dont est en fait j'étais vulnérable à
ce moment là et même moi je me suis je
me suis vu faire la pâte en abattant à
temps par magna s'attend à ce que je
croyais qu'un nouveau variant attend
avec la main qui tremble ça à 30 ans il
ya un nouveau variant là ils ont plus un
truc partir d un chien est en fait à
lire et de me retrouver à la fin il n'en
attend en fait à temps a fait dans sa va
cesser c'est pas sûr en fait et mai
prochains et mes arrêts de jeu devenait
complètement cinglé je ne faisais que et
quand je me suis appelé c'est à dire que
c'était tellement en continu que ça a
fini par même moi qui qui qui dit depuis
longtemps jean on n'écoutait pas tout
prenez du recul machin mais moi je me
suis fait happer par ce truc c'était la
surenchère de la mort tous les jours
tous les jours tous les jours tous les
jours l'angoissent on monte les gens les
uns contre les autres le gouvernement
invente iliz et les gens nous parlait
comme des gamins vous pourrez aller
courir à 18h et si vous êtes sages à
noël on vous laissera sortir enfin
c'était je mets
un incroyable jeu j'ai trouvé j'ai
trouvé cette période
j'ai trouvé que cette période était
vraiment
il y avait après j'ai que 37 ans tu vois
et hormis évidemment des guerres et des
trucs mais j'ai trouvé que cette période
était abominable à vivre je pense qu'ils
ont vraiment fait du mal vraiment fait
du mal aux gens et même moi qui ai la
chance d'être assez je crois solide et
d'avoir une vie choix est une vie que
j'aime et c'est même moi je vois qu'ils
ont créé des traumatismes dans ma tête
c'est à dire que là où je n'avais jamais
eu peur qu'on parle qu'on annule mes
tournées maintenant il se passe le
moindre truc le moindre truc j'ai
l'impression qu'on va manul aimé tourner
le mais le met des trucs autrement
absurde
il va se passer un truc dans un pays je
m'entends de dire un rythme à temps
parce que s'il ya ça peut-être qu'il va
se passer ça et ça et du coup peut-être
ils vont nous élus et donc tu vois serre
qui m'ont ils m'ont même mois ils ont
ravagé la tête et je te parle même pas
de je te parle même pas des gosses qui
ont qui avec des masques en permanence
où les étudiants
dramatique enfin tout le monde s'est
pris une énorme gifle et tout le monde
ne s'en est pas relevé et en grande
partie en grande partie à cause du
comportement des médias et du
comportement de ce gouvernement les deux
ensemble mais c'était un truc quand même
et séné mais enfin mais c'est vous
pouvez être un tout petit peu optimiste
arrêtez de nous parler comme dsk et si
tu te mettre à leur place
oui
j'ai essayé de mettre à leur place mais
tu n'es pas en fait
tu n'es pas obligé de faire peur aux
gens quel est le président a
peut-être les gens qui n'ont rien ne
s'en rappelleront mais je sais que quand
tu m'as kron a déclaré nous sommes en
guerre je sais qu'il ya un président ou
une présidente je sais plus dans quel
moment il le dit beaucoup ouais on
regarde tout le temps
il ya un président ou une présidente je
sais plus dans quelle partie du monde
qui a fait exprès qu'à faire un truc
sans bon nous on n'est pas en guerre
mais on va devoir faire attention t'es
pas obligé de prêter tu vois il ya
quelqu'un qui sait qui a fait dans son
discours officiels karin référence avec
macron quant à des caisses il était
demandé mais t'es pas obligé enfin on
n'est pas des débiles mentaux t'es pas
obligé de nous faire croire toutes les
secondes qu'on va tous mourir pour con
pour con pour qu'on soit attentif pour
qu'on soit intelligent bien sûr que sur
une population totale tu aura toujours
des gens qui seront pas qu'ils seront
qui ont qui ont envie de faire chier y
aura des gens qui sont bien sûr mais moi
je ne pars pas du principe que la
majorité des français sont des mongols
majorité des gens tu es obligé de leur
dire qu'ils vont crever que si leur
grand mère tombe malade et meurt ça sera
de leur faute parce qu'ils n'ont pas mis
le masque je crois pas que tu sois
obligé de faire une publicité tu t'es tu
as vu cette publicité où il ya une
gamine qui va l'anniversaire de sa
grand-mère sans masque et l'image
d'après c'est sa grand-mère qui meurt en
réanimation
on est obligé de faire ça il pense à
l'impact doit ça m'énerve je n'ai pas
d'enfant c'est j'imagine l'impact de la
gamine de 6 7 ans sur son canapé tu pour
certains gros bras quand tu 10h banon
magret déjà est déjà décédé
malheureusement mes tubes tue pas tu
prends par exemple tu prends une gamine
de 6 7 ans qui tombe sur cette pub et il
se trouve que la grand-mère elle est
vraiment morte
il se passe quoi dans le cerveau de
cette petite fille
nos familles mais on fait quoi là on a
on a des pubs payés par le gouvernement
où on dit à des gosses à tort de
paisibles pardoux oui papa et par nous
ont dit à des gamins potentiellement
site a embrassé ta grand mère sans masse
à cause de toi qu'elle va crever mais
enfin mais qui sont ces gens il faut les
mettre en prison des gens qu'on fait ça
enfin c'est pas possible on peut pas
faire ça aux gens on n'est pas obligé de
dire aux gens on n'est pas obligé de
terroriser une population n'est pas
obligé de faire ça on n'est pas obligé
de faire ça la stratégie de la peur bien
sûr mais la stratégie de la peur toute
façon on sait très bien tu sais le faire
des trucs que je disais d'ailleurs dans
vente de pièces à beyrouth je disais que
quand par exemple un président quand
quand un président est en guerre quelque
part quand il une guerre quelque part
les sondages remonte parce que les gens
ont peur et la première chose que les
gens font quand ils ont peur c'est
qu'ils fixent
tu as dire que par exemple temps en
temps un bruit tu sais pas d'où il vient
qu'est ce que tu fais tu regardes autour
de toi mais tu regardes pas seulement
d'où vient le bruit tu as sur tout ce
qui est autour de toi tu as peur tu te
crise que tu tiens ce qu'elle a tu vois
c'est quand un reporter de guerre non
mais parce que j'ai travaillé sur la
guerre avec mais là il ya quelqu'un qui
arrive là qu'est ce qu'on va faire tous
les trois et un mec qui arrive à quai ce
qu'on a fait on a tous sont regroupés
ensemble tu vas donc
la stratégie de la peur il l'avait
utilisé de la même manière avec les
attentats ils ont utilisé de la même
manière avec les attentats c'est ce que
c'est ce qui m'a valu la grosse dispute
avec manuel valls sur le plateau d'on
n'est pas couché j'ai dit arrêtez
arrêtez de faire flipper les gens tout
le temps mc ronde le fait que ça je
trouve que tu mets tu l'entends parler
mais moi tu sais que et pourtant j'ai il
faut que je les écoute parce qu'il faut
que je sache un peu et tout mais je n'y
arrive plus il me il me flingue la tête
je te dire un truc pour ça les discours
de macron il faut les écouter avec une
petite douce mélopée derrière jean la
musique
tu n'as pas du tout écouter elle a
débuté
juste juste une douce mélopée derrière
jean la musique de manon des sources
et jean de florette il est ensuite
canalise le tempo et tout de suite ça
prend une autre dimension tu as une
autre perception de météorites pas le
sorgho à c'était quand même la santé
coûte en fait tu t'écoutes le discours
de macron avec cette petite musique ou
de la musique d'ascenseur ça marche
aussi avec où je vais écouter on doit
finir cette énergie est rentré chez moi
et je vais essayer mais manon des
sources d'accord ou jean de florette
promis je vais essayer je sais que je
devrai une vidéo je t'envie le tous les
discours ça n'est que je vois c'est
quand même que ça la rentrée va être
très dur on va on va traverser des
périodes extrêmement compliqué il faut
que les français se préparent
mais quelque chose alors moi j'ai pas
une théorie fixer là dessus je me dis à
plusieurs choses il ya plusieurs
possibilités soit il est extrêmement
pessimistes ou réalistes et qu'ils
essayent de près de prévenir sa
population
sans s'en trouver les mots pour quand il
fait ses grands effets de manche oui le
gouvernement se doit d'être super
transparent de communiqué interne et à
écouter s'il est réaliste moi je moi je
oui mais s'il est réaliste ça veut dire
qu'il n'a aucun projet
banon mais parce que si les raismois je
voulais imaginons alors on part du
principe qu'il est réaliste mais
moralement c'est lui qui doit te trouver
ce processus pour le dire il ya un hiver
qui arrive oui il est réaliste
on doit changer de capitaine parce que
si c'est pour me dire normalement il a
dit hier et je vais requérir nous allons
passer des heures difficiles mais j'ai
quelques solution à vous proposer c'est
juste pour me dire ça va être l'enfer en
permanence parce que c'est que ça
bonsoir alors bon assez laid on va
passer une rentrée extrêmement compliqué
l'été va être dur
le mot noël va être très compliqué nous
allons passer un hiver rude [__] c'est
l'enfer on dirait charles ingalls qui a
perdu une récolte et qui est lent mais
enfin c'est pas possible on a celle du
char eagles ne perd pas de récolte ça
lui est arrivé à charles ingalls on
dirait charles ingalls mais c'est sans
déconner tu sais il rentre dans la pièce
je vois vraiment cette image de charline
gaz qui a perdu la récolte à cause de la
grêle et tout l'hôtel à la syphilis
l'hôtel est en train de mourir en
accouchant rien sa fille aveugle et
comme ça doit l'acheminer et anti fait
on va passer un hiver très difficile tu
vas tu veux pas à chaque fois que tu
prends la parole dire aux gens vous
allez souffrir tu peux pas en perdre ça
ne peut pas être ton seul leitmotiv de
temps en temps tu veu diret et bon
accueil le but et ses pages c'est pas
fou il ya deux trois trucs ça va être ça
va passer juste mais ça va aller ça va
aller tu vois non la peur la peur
d'aller mourir vous allez mourir de
lardons vérone où vous allez mourir lui
coville vos proches vont mourir du coc
vide à cause de vous ensuite étaient
coupées votre wifi sinon les gens de
montrond de froid à coates peu fou qu on
met les sens et 8 euros le litre au fait
en fait fait que fait comme vous pourrez
mais bon c'est 8 euros lead sachez le je
te fasse peur d'aller live du chauffeur
a eu un vif émoi
nous comptons les voix parlée surtout
surtout gabriela talent d'accord tu vaux
gabriel bon il a fait d'énormes progrès
quand même parce qu'il est quand même
obligé d'un nouveau poste maintenant je
sais c'est plutôt je sais plus trop où
il est là il devrait on sait plus en
plus les secrétaires de schéma dans
lequel il est obligé quand même
d'annoncer tout ça tu sais que nous on
bosse sur les fonds les fondamentaux de
soutenabilité de notre société comme
l'énergie
le terrorisme des mouvements sociaux
commencer à articuler les phénomènes de
guerre à des phénomènes de pollution de
destruction du biotope dieu sait si ces
petites choses
[Musique]
et nous quand on les voit et qu'on
allait les chiffres par exemple de
consommation énergétique ou les
capacités de substitution de 2 du marché
énergétique de la russie est-ce qu'on a
d'autres d'autres marchés qui peuvent
s'ouvrir où est ce qu'on va est obligé
de [__] avec le lait ce qui mixe les
journalistes dans les ambassades
où est ce qu'on va été obligée d'avaler
des couleuvres à gauche et à droite et
si réellement on a la capacité de
récupérer notre stock énergétique pour
éviter une récession dramatique comme on
bosse sur les phénomènes de guerre
économique on sait qu'un chômeur coûte
plus cher qu'un mort et que quand il
commença siens une guerre économique
ouverte ça commence à être problématique
surtout que qui ne comprennent pas
l'idéologie et la perception de la
guerre économique que les russes peuvent
avoir tué les américains en terme de
guerre économique ethnique
mythique avec le sourire voilà hangar
économique on est bien parce qu'on a
quand même bruno le maire a down qui
parle pas de bonnes affaires c'est fier
qu'on arrivera chez nous non 2 il a
raison
sauf qu'il n'a pas compris qu'on fasse
donc je te terme et les américains c'est
typique mais avec le sourire et puis tu
retournes le sourire genre c'est win win
mais en fait c'est oui wind que pour eux
tu as mais ça hein ça y met du temps à
comprendre du côté russe la guerre
économique n est pas du tout perçue
comme ça la guerre économique c'est ils
ont de l'entraînement ils ont subi et
que eux quand ils se fâchent en guerre
économique
il tarde ashley dans une à une avec une
taille bien moyenâgeuse parce que pour
eux un chien qui a plus de dons c'est un
chien qui mord pu et donc ça c'est un
gros problème les questions de subtilité
de guerre économique quand on entend le
gouvernement parler de guerre économique
ou de parler de problèmes
d'approvisionnement énergétique
on entend leur angoisse parce qu'ils
sont en train de prendre conscience des
chiffres et les mets qui balisent et
dont qui communiquent leur peur à
travers leurs discours et d'ailleurs ça
c'est encore un bon exemple parce que
il ya encore il ya encore très peu de
temps et je pense qu'il ya encore une
partie des gens qui sont l'outil qu'est
la plupart des gens sont convaincus je
pense or ils pas tous hein ce que ça
commence qu'à la sortie 1 mais qu' on va
si on manque de gaz cet hiver ce sera
dur ça sera ça sera à qu'offensivement
si on manque d'énergie ce sera à cause
du conflit en ukraine tu vois il ya que
maintenant vaincu oui mais c'est ça que
j'ai dit c'est que c'est exactement ça
que je dis c'est que la plus la plupart
des gens sont convaincus parce qu'ils
ont ils ont mis le problème ils ont
insidieusement ils nous ont ils nous ont
tranquillement
sous-entendu que les problèmes
énergétiques qu'on allait avoir c'était
en grande partie à cause des problèmes
avec avec du conflit entre l'ukraine et
la russie alors qu'en fait quand tu
creuses le truc tu t'aperçois que
si nos problèmes internes à notre pays
était résolu entre guillemets ça se
passerait à priori plutôt plutôt pas mal
et que l'ukraine et la russie c'est pas
une grosse grosse part je parlais
quantifier ça j'ai pas assez creusé le
sujet mais c'est pas forcément une part
majoritaire dans les problèmes
énergétiques on va voir si c'est une
grosse part c'est c'est pas la totalité
du groupe c'est une grosse faim et en
termes de substitution ils sont en train
de dormir tout le monde en disant oui on
va trouver des substitutions non mais
c'est une grosse part parce que parce
que parce que tu as besoin d'eux pour
combler les carences interne c'est ça
que je veux dire c'est pas c'est pas ce
que je veux dire c'est pas que c'est pas
une grosse part oui c'est une grosse
part parce que on n'a pas de quoi
fabriquer notre énergie sur place mais
si tu savais fabrique et énergie sur pas
ça serait moins une grosse pas mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que ça au plus
vif succès oui mais je trouve qu'en tout
cas la manière dont ça a été racontée
aux gens
moi personnellement il ya encore pas si
longtemps ce pour ça que c'est pas très
précis sur le lit ce que je viens juste
de creuser un petit peu le truc mais il
ya encore pas si longtemps j'étais quand
même convaincu que le problème majeur
c'était quand même se complique c'est
pas non plus que ça quand quand tu quand
tu creuses un peu que tu vois les
problèmes avec les centrales nucléaires
l'épreuve d'entretien l'épreuve de
personnes à l'époque du bon il n'ya pas
c'est pas le seul problème et je trouve
qu'on a on nous a quand même encore une
fois un peu dévié tous là dessus pour un
peu caché le reste du truc tu en
avais fait une manche
à prestidigitateur la politique ne le
cas rue st c'est révélateur de tout un
tas de saloperies mais c'est aussi je
dévie je n'aurai pas de parler de ça les
russes ça arrangeait bien les partis
politiques européens qu'on leur
fournisse pour leur économie de
l'énergie pas cher c'est le principe du
dealer donc ils peuvent régalé tout le
monde je suis le président de la
croissance le président du pouvoir
d'achat en allemagne c'était à gogo ce
genre d'argument aussi sauf que les
russes et les mâles quand il ferme le
robinet était dépendant et que tu testes
société hyper spécialisés et hyper
dépend de l'énergie pas cher là il
fallait quand même anticipé le fait que
combien c'est leur coup pourquoi ils
vont aussi pas chez impôts
écoutez le prochain tu fasses un truc
sur la guerre économique le prochain
spectacle on va être à être sur
l'écologie très certainement parce que
je trouve qu'il ya plus que juste
éteignons nos radiateurs et commencer un
peu plus complexe que ça et je hais le
sujet le sujet mais déjà je pense qu'il
est nécessaire je pense qu'il faut en
parler déjà parce que justement tu vois
il ya toutes ces questions sait jamais
quoi ts qu'une voiture a même eu tu
prends une voiture électrique en mai
mais tu sais ce qu'il faut pour
fabriquer la batterie donc tu mets des
éoliennes oui mais des crabes immer bon
tu mets donc j'aimerais bien déjà voir
ça tu vois les chasseurs oui mais ils
régulent s qui régule voir fait tu vois
essayez de de creuser un peu tous ces
sujets des sujets un peu bateau mais
parce que c'est des sujets qui viennent
tout le temps dans la tête des gens et
en fait tout le monde dit un peu
n'importe quoi même mois d'un fois je me
suis surpris je tenterai de m'emballer
sur un sujet à la fois à table avec des
amis en régime et qu'est ce que je
raconte jean sait absolument rien j'ai
longuement fait je me dis
c'est qu'il faisait quatre titres sur
internet et je suis en train de me faire
une théorie ce qu est ce que tu as lu le
tu parle d'écologie avec la guerre la
guerre avec les russes c'est pour ça que
je le rencontrais là-dessus ce parce que
du coup l'énergie maintenant fait partie
intégrante et on s'aperçoit que quand on
creuse d'énergie j'ai commencé un tout
petit peu en fait c'est encore un truc
c'est encore un dis-toi que l'énergie
c'est c'est la sève de tous
l'acef de tout tout tout
tu peux faire des parallèles entre
l'énergie le terrorisme quand les gens
ils ont ils ont plus debout facile ils
ont pu de soins facile ils ont plus de
service public facile parce que
l'énergie c'est ça quand tu as pu
d'énergie battait service public qui
morfle ta bouffe elle coûte plus cher
parce que une calorie fauci du mois une
calories ingurgitées produites ces sept
calories fossiles c'est des choses comme
ça qu'il faut prendre est-ce que tu as
lu est ce que tu as eu le truc sur ont
ré où vous des centrales à charbon
circuit depuis la guerre il ya plus de
problèmes d'écologie et j'ai rapidement
gelé vu passer quoi j'ai vu juste et je
me suis pas plonger du tout dans le truc
mais j'ai vu j'ai vu j'ai vu le truc
passé j'ai vu le truc passé mais après
encore une fois tu sais moi j'aime pas
trop quand quand je maîtrise pas bien un
sujet n'aime pas trop donner mon avis
parce que parce que je trouve qu'on est
sûr gaver d'infos je dis pas que quand
je parle je dis que des vérités un ca
peu marre ils me tromper ou de mal mal
m'exprimer ça c'est là c'est la vie
c'est normal mais disons que
quand je connais pas bien sûr j'y vais
plus en fait parce que eu de la censure
pas de son show te fait un push et
d'indochine
ou écoute j'ai aucun problème de censure
je dis la vérité je sais qu'il y en a
qui en souffre je sais qu'il ya des gens
que l'on qui ça peut arriver d'être
censuré moi j'ai une vraiment une totale
liberté ton partout où je vais on ne
censure plus appuyé à sa a pu
on a pu menacer de censure dans dans le
passé mais ça n'est jamais vraiment
arriver quand on a censuré de façon je
suis plus jamais revenue peinture donc
donc là c'est ben en fait j'étais en
train de réfléchir en même temps est en
fait en même temps je te disais je
disais même temps j'ai même pas
d'exemple de qui m'a censuré donc non
non pas censuré mais par exemple
par exemple tu vois un banc de neige
devaient intégrer une devra intégrer une
matinale
et on m'avait dit j'ai senti que quand
je faisais j'avais fait des essais et je
sentais que les gars commencent à me
dire ça mais ça tu le dises comme ça ça
tu lis comme ça te du coup là dès que
j'avais ça je t'ai jamais ça je partais
intégrer les grosses têtes jeu sera en
fait c'est les grossesses je le fais
depuis longtemps je le fais de ça fait
cinq ans bah ça s'écoute c'est normal ça
fait cinq ou six ça oui et au temps en
temps mais pas tout le temps il n'y a
pas de toutes les émissions c'est les
petits prime font des prêts ne sont pas
les premières 30 ans sur france télé
mais ça fait des années que j'ai la
grosse tête mais après l'ag pas pu y
aller l'année dernière ce que j'avais
beaucoup trop de dates de tournée mais
sinon j'essaye dès que je peux j'y vais
parce que je m'amuse beaucoup ces pays
oui bien sûr
alors c'est totalement aléatoire c'est
pas je botte pas en touche c'est
complètement at war et je n'ai aucune
ajoute toujours c'est vrai je n'ai
aucune idée de combien sont payés les
gens je sais qu'il ya des salaires qui
peuvent aller 2-3 s'emballe je crois que
ça c'est à peu près le plus grave est
sûr et ça monte moi je crois que c'est
mais
je ne suis pas sûr je redis je ne suis
pas sûr je le dis bien je crois que les
plus bas salaires c'est dans ces eaux là
mais je ne suis pas sûr je crois que
quand tu arrives c'est à peu près dans
autour de ces quelques centaines d'euros
mais c'est un c'est un truc comme ça que
je crois c'est pas du tout une certitude
peut-être que je me trompe complètement
c'est pas payer des fortunes mais c'est
bien payé pour l'exercice les unes
regard toi et tout le respect que je te
dauger directeur saltimbanques
telara vision de la société et les
humoristes les chanteurs l'aller les
arts en général sont là pour cesser les
premiers lanceurs d'alerté on dit
toujours utilisé l'humour pour dénoncer
les choses parce que sinon ils vont
sa cage et toi comment tu parles on est
pas on n'est pas beaucoup à sa serrure
de l'humour pour lancer des alertes mais
ça c'est pas une critique c'est je
transpire il fait chaud c'est chaud chez
toi voilà après qui sait très bien bravo
au gouvernement de féliciter pour sa
sobriété
pas on n'a pas des bronches et le wifi
parce que tu comprends
encore beaucoup de basse consommation
ouais ouais ça c'est rien consommer
c'est l'impression qu'on est en plein
mois après son conte et le 15 juillet
sur une terrasse
dans une
quatrième étoile chez kodak à
la question c'était quoi comment tu
perçois ce qui se passe donc ça le
saltimbanque
notre société est là tu la sens bien où
tu sens que ça va partir en sucette
ça va tu crois encore à la résilience
des gens la solidarité sai moi je crois
je crois que les je pense que ça va être
un peu le spectacle sur l'écologie je
pense que je vais l'axé d'ailleurs un
peu là dessus
tu vois avec avec allelujah bordel ont
souhaité que soit la religion j'essaie
de dire aux gens à arrêter de vous taper
dessus pour des croyances accepter ou
les uns des autres un peu en insultant
tout le monde mais c'était ça le message
tous ne peuvent pas compris
vent de pièces à beyrouth j'essaie de
mettre un peu les gens en colère autant
dire réveillez vous sur ce qui se passe
à l'étranger parce que vous pouvez vous
en [__] mais le prix de votre essence
sakho ça sera c'est ce qui se passe là
bas qui va impacter ça donc
réveillez-vous anesthésie générale c'est
autre chose comme j'évoque mes troubles
psychiatriques les trucs des machins
n'en parlera peut-être après que
j'évoque tout ça
là c'était une manière de leur dire
prenez soin de vous parce que vous
pouvez vous en sortir même si tout
s'effondre autour de vous vous avez une
base pour vous en sortir et vous pouvez
aller mieux quelles que soient vos
problèmes quels que soient vos troubles
même si vous tombez sur des mêmes
optiques à des mauvais médecin des
mauvais même même si c'est vous pouvez
vous en sortir il ya la manière de s'en
sortir
le quatrième spectacle je pense que je
vais vraiment axé sur arrêtez de dire
que vous ne pouvez rien faire
ne tombez pas dans l'isère à nos dix
tours mais qu'est ce que tu veux que je
fasse moi je suis je suis agent de
sécurité est ce que tu veux gérer c'est
pas une critique je sais que mon père
est agent de ces cas c'est de dire à mon
père ou à ma mère si vous pouvez faire
quelque chose vous pouvez en réalité on
peut tous faire quelque chose déjà parce
que je pense que la politique n'a jamais
été aussi soucieuse de l'opinion
publique rendez-vous musi avec un
général mais ça c'est incroyable c'est à
dire que
je trouve ça vraiment incroyable c'est à
dire que quand tu regardes twitter et tu
regardes et tu regarde le jt avec makoun
qui prend des décisions team c'est pas
possible ou fait il a passé la journée
sur twitter il répond à ce que j'ai lu
là il répond là est ce que j'ai lu là
donc c'est quand même
pour moi c'est une absurdité
et puis parce que
au lieu de se plaindre tout le temps
qu'on est dans un système capitaliste et
que l'argent prime en permanence et
c'est justement en réalité tu as quand
même ta réponse dans ta quand tu sers
que
ton arme c'est ton pouvoir d'achat c'est
ce que tu vas acheter c'est ce que tu va
consommer c'est pas que le vote tu vois
il ya quelqu'un qui disait ça j'suis pas
qu'ils aient la phrase n'est pas de moi
mais ton vote c'est ce que tu achètes et
et j'aimerais bien arriver
pas dire pas leur donner de leçons de
morale aux gens je vais pas qu'un stade
dans l'écologie pour dire aux gens à
arrêter de manger du bifteck c'est pas
je vais pas me lancer dans la morale et
ça c'est pas du tout mon délire moi je
veux pas juger les gens je suis pas du
tout là dedans ce que ce que j'aimerais
arriver à faire dans ce prochain
spectacle j'espère que je vais y arriver
j'ai pas encore commencé à l'écrire
c'est c'est que quand ils vont j'espère
quand ils vont ressortir le spectacle
kooza [__] en fait
en fait je peux me venger je peux les
faire chier je peux je peux je peux
exprimer ma voix autrement que par un
vote tous les cinq ans
d'autres votes 6 qu'il faut pas se
venger qu'il faut pas faire chier il
faut construire sans doute oui mais il
ya les gens c'est à dire que
quand quand tu quand tu subis quand tu
subis en fait il ya des gens qui
subissent la vie subi ce système dans
dans une société pas les gens tu as les
gens tuent leur tape dessus ils vont se
relever on invasive à ça me rend plus
fort est aux pieds des gens ils n'ont
pas de caractère ils n'ont pas sinon pas
ça et c'est pas grave c'est à nous de
leur dire tiens lui il a du mal alors on
va l'aider à se relever c'est ça une
société c c'était il ya des gens on peut
pas juste dire aux gens moi je pourrais
le dire tu vois je viens d'un milieu
extrêmement modestes j'avais rien je
connaissais personne je suis pas allé à
l'école j'ai pas le bac j'ai rien je
suis arrivé à paris j'ai buté en 93
avant j'habitais au silence d'un autre
quartier je pourrais très bien dire mais
battez-vous mauges d'ailleurs rien ben
moi je suis pas d'accord avec ça parce
que je pense que c'est pas vrai il ya
des gens il ya des gens qui n'ont pas
forcément cette force alors il faut leur
dire qu'ils ont la force il faut leur
dire lève toi et va travailler mais il
faut accepter que de temps en temps ils
savaient pas aussi vite que toi faut
accepter qu'il y ait des gens qui sont
un peu plus abîmée faut accepter ça les
faux les faux les aider à se relever ses
taux et
quand je dis se venger quand je dis tout
ça c'est pas
pour dans ma bouche c'est pas agressif
c'est c'la c'est la manière dont moi je
me suis motivé tu vois c'est chacun
trouve sa motivation il y en a ils vont
dire je veux que mes parents soient
fiers il y en a ils vont dire je veux
que je veux rendre tu sais tu entends
souvent ça les artistes lisa ce prof il
m'a dit que jamais je serai personnes et
ils on parle encore tu vois il on parle
encore tout le temps tu vois j'entendais
encore des big flo et oli là j'ai fait
écouter le nouvel album il repart encore
de leur prof qui leur disaient comment
ce que je comprends très bien et donc
quand je dis ça c'est parce que moi
c'est comme ça que je me motive tu vois
il n'y a pas d'agressivité physique n'y
a pas de destruction physique c'est
juste tient en fait j'ai un pouvoir j'ai
eu l'impression de subir une injustice
je peux avoir un sentiment de vengeance
je peux avoir la possibilité de de
donner mon avis de manière un peu plus
conséquente parce qu'en réalité il ya
que ça qui marche il ya que ça qui
marche c'est je pense que la manière
dont tu vis à plus d'impact que la
manière parfois pas toujours mais que la
manière dont tu vas voter je pense que
parfois 60 millions de personnes qui
changent de manière de vivre de vivre
entre 60 millions de personnes qui vont
voter
honnêtement je ne sais pas ce qui aura
le plus d'impact réel sur la société
mais je pense que au vu de qui financent
et campagne électorale à mon avis la
consommation a plus d'impact parfois que
le vote
tu seras pas ce que disait coluche
sur la sur ces gens n'achetaient pas ça
se vendrait pas
oui mais voilà
revenons à des troubles psychiatriques
cette affiche quoi
déjà de notre chère diagnostiqués parce
que tu as accepté ita pas accepté est ce
que c'est a fait du bien pas du bien ça
tu es ouvert des portes cette année des
pistes
en gros je peux difficilement répondre à
cette question comme ça mais je peux que
je dirige mon nom je lui réponds à mes
grands plaisirs et les branchements un
grand plaisir et puis si si même ça peut
aider certaines personnes et je me suis
exprimé sur le sujet déjà et je le fais
vraiment avec vraiment vraiment avec
plaisir j'ai aucune honte ça ne gêne
absolument pas tu me poser toutes les
questions que
moi j'ai toujours senti que j'avais des
problèmes dans ma tête et donc ça déjà
petit tu vas déjà petit c'était pas ça
n'allait pas quoi il y avait ça je
n'étais jamais bien déjà petit san à
l'aise ça n'a absolument jamais moi j'ai
grandi dans une ville où cieux
on appelle ça bélair nous chez nous les
gens des gens de charleville qui
m'écoutent france avaler fait rien on se
bat et on va donner à bel-air tu sais
c'était une manière de dire ah bah t'es
ouf doit tomber dans un truc de bel-air
c'était un hôpital psychiatrique et nous
pour nous c'était les fous tu vois on
emmenait les fous à bel-air tu vois donc
du coup tous tes problèmes dans ta tête
déjà quand tu es petit tu en parles pas
parce que c'est soit tu sois tu es fou
tu vas à bel-air soi mais ça va ça va ou
pas ouais ouais du coup ça va tu portes
un truc ça va et puis en fait ça ne va
pas et puis donc ça augmente et
augmenter augmenté augmenté et puis
après ça a commencé à marcher donc
là-bas naïvement je me dire ah bah c'est
super maintenant j'ai mes salles qui
sont pleines en plus j'ai réussi sans
corrompre je crois en tout cas envie je
crois je crois oui oui en fait oui je me
suis réfugié sans rompre en essayant de
des mémos public de faire du bien aux
gens je suis fier de ce que je raconte
sur scène même si parfois je peux dire
des conneries faire des erreurs mais
demain mais je le fais vraiment et
bienveillant ces jeunes vraiment tout
mon coeur est un donc je suis fier de ça
et donc j'ai 25 ans ça commence à
marcher je monte mes sociétés tout
marche tu vois et là je me dis bien tous
ces trucs qui m'ont pas dans ma tête ça
va se calmer et puis cette envie de
boire permanente avec laquelle je dois
me battre tout le temps tu vois si ça va
passer tout va passer et puis ça passe
pas et puis commença à boire boire à
boire boire boire beaucoup je tombe dans
un truc où je dois vraiment 6 litres de
vin par jour enfin je tombe je fais des
phases avec médicaments avec machin
enfin je sais ça va pas du tout quoi et
je me retrouve en une fenêtre où je suis
une tempête je me suicide la chance que
je vais avoir là c'est la vie pourtant
je suis pas croyant mais là quand même
michael mon associé donc que tu connais
bon j'ai parlé tout à l'heure à quel
étage j'étais le plus haut de l'otage
était juste pas exactement gens ça mais
j'étais très enfin suffit je sais que
j'étais au dessus des arbres parce que
je me rappelle que je disais à michael
les arbres je disais à michael les
arbres gîte 18 juillet dix sont des
excroissances de la mort
tiens j'avais les phrases comme ça donc
j'étais plus
n'était pas sur le banc j'étais un peu
dans l'esprit macron très sombre avec
avec des heures difficiles et donc je
suis à voir de la fenêtre et tout ça
mika est pas là et tout et puis et puis
j'étais avec ma copine de l'époque qui
part parce qu'on s'est discutée bla bla
bla ouais et puis en fait en partant
elle va voir michael et puis elle me dit
bon je me casse on s'est pris la tête et
tout puis elle lui donne la clé de notre
chambre et puis me cachais pas
le pif quoi ils montent et donc ils me
voient au bord de la fenêtre oui je vais
me parler machin je vais finir par je
fais un parent très bon j'explique ça un
peu plus en détail dans ce spectacle
enfin peu importe de là je vais aller
voir des psychiatres et puis là je
rencontre d'autres des meilleurs et
qu'ils vont commencer à me donner un bon
diagnostic et après je rentre en cure de
désintox parce que ça fait des années
que j'ai des problèmes d'alcool donc en
trois mois je mets des murs j'ai
d'ailleurs les gens qui me suivent
savent pas ce que je montais le poids tu
vois je voulais en réalité mon corps je
réussissais pas plus que ça c'est
surtout ma tête parce que je faisais
encore un peu aussi un forcément mais ça
c'était les phases alcool pas l'alcool
parce que je me reprenait et [__] je
suis alcoolique je dis que j'ai un
problème il faudrait donc je retourne au
sport en quatre mois et puis je
reprenais l'alcool de plus belle et
cetera puis un jour je perds le contrôle
et là j'arrive à des ados talent cole
hallucinante ayant fait j'y arriverai
jamais arrêté de boire donc je vais en
cure de désintox je me paye une cure
incroyable en suisse hors de prix pour
les français ou bien c'était 30000 euros
le mois
en gros c'est mille balles par jour en
sachant que en suisse
c'est remboursé là-bas parleurs leur
espèce de sécurité sociale bon puis
trente mille euros en france enfin 30000
euros pour un suisse et 30000 euros pour
un français sait pas exactement même
chose donc c'est cher de base et puis
c'est cher aussi parce que l'économie
suisse on le sait est supérieur pourquoi
je vais là-bas pas parce que c'est cher
je vais là-bas parce que je sais qu'on
ne verra pas j'ai pas envie de parler de
ça j'ai pas envie qu'on boit et c est là
bas je sais que on est dans un endroit
c'est complètement verrouillé n'y a pas
de journalistes il ya personne qui parle
et tout ça donc je et puis je sais aussi
que c'est l'une des meilleures cure et
je sais qu'en france les cures sont
mauvaises parce que en france très
compliqué l'alcool il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de de lobby très puissant qui
entoure aussi nos
politiques etc tu vois là ils vont
bientôt lancer des grosses campagnes de
prévention on va voir et j'espère qu'ils
vont me lancer des campagnes de
prévention sur l'alcool parce que faut
quand même rappeler que l'alcool le
tabac c'est quand même voilà donc donc
je rends dans cette cure de désintox et
puis là et là je vais faire plein plein
plein de tests un comportementaliste
psychiatre machin enfin voilà tout un
tout un tas de trucs et donc là on va me
faire une liste de deux troubles et ça a
été le plus beau jour de ma vie
ça a été plus beau jour de ma vie parce
que les maladies invisible on appelle ça
des malades invisible c'est des troubles
que tu que tu ne peux pas voir
parce que tu ne peux pas les verbaliser
surtout qu'elle ne se voit pas c'est à
dire que moi je suis obsessionnel
compulsif idée hâtive j'ai un trou de
l'attention hyperactivité
voilà j'ai plusieurs troubles comme ça
et ça ne se voit pas on ne le voit pas
tu me vois comme ça tu peux pas te dire
ce mec il a des images horribles dans sa
tête qui lui donne envie de se jeter par
un balcon du mode de la première minute
avec l islam jusqu'à la dernière une
telle crise couche donc tu peux pas
imaginer ça et c'est très compliqué de
le verbaliser donc
donc toutes ces maladies invisible qui
qui qui tue plein de gens mais souvent
par suicide parce que le problème c'est
que
ce qui est très compliqué que les
maladies psychiatriques
en tout cas celles qui invisible les
autres on les connaît bien tu vois la
schizophrénie la vie polarité sont des
troubles identifiés parce que quand même
ça se voit il ya des troubles très très
palpable en société donc tout de suite
on identifie et on peut on peut essayer
de soigner puis à des traitements etc
etc mais
ces troubles la son son
t'as pas de mots pour les décrire et les
seuls mots que tu as pour les décrire ce
sont des maux de la vie quotidienne je
souffre je vois des images sont obsédés
par tu vois donc ça donc ça ça sonne
très vite même dans les mêmes dans la
tête des gens qui t'aiment ça sonne très
vite communes comme une mélodie qui
connaissent donc quand tu te confie aux
gens et que le rediffuser g sage et ça
les gens souvent te dise pas aimé moi
aussi j'ai ça sauf que ce qui en fait
une maladie psychiatrique népal s'est
pas lassé pas le sentiment c'est la
fréquence la violence avec laquelle ça
vient l'intensité et est donc ces
troubles et aussi pour les reds et alors
c'est que c'est compliqué trop beaux
sites souvent de très bon psychiatre
elle va ces gens s'enferment les proches
font tout ce qu'ils peuvent mais ils ne
comprennent pas en réalité la personne
ne sait pas ce cas là elle va voir des
psychiatres mois les psychiatres il se
foutait de ma gueule j'ai vu j'ai vu
beaucoup de psychiatres heureusement
après j'en ai trouvé des géniaux qui
m'ont quand même sauvé la vie donc je
peux pas c'est pour ça que tu vois c'est
toujours mais j'en ai vu ils se sont
foutus de my own m'ont ri au nez je leur
expliquer ce qui se passait bien
c'est le succès
plutôt quelqu'un avait okaka donc
c'était
et donc et donc et donc danseuses et
donc le jour où j'ai des psys qui me
font malice de maladie je te jure ça a
été le plus beau jour de ma vie je crois
que j'ai pleuré de joie j'ai pleuré de
joie parce que je me suis dit [__] je
suis
j'ai rien à inventer parce que tu en
arrives à te demander tu en arrives à
dire ça en fait peut-être que j'invente
parce que tu as des gens qui se confie
pas des gens qui se confie un peu plus
des gens qui se confie beaucoup donc moi
au début je vous confiez pas perdre et
j'ai dit en fait il faut que je parle il
faut que ça sorte tu vois et au bout
d'un moment mais tu as les gens ils
finissent par te dire bonjour m ok tu
vois ça c'est un truc de la vie bon
c'est la vie ça c'est rien tient et donc
est donc au bout d'un moment tu te dis
bah en fait je suis je suis je suis je
suis juste un juge d'un collard en fait
je suis réagit à tout parce que ça
génère les troupes que j'ai ça génère
plein de comportement et donc je suis
juste un connard juge jour un coup un
connard quand rajoute donc tu détestes
tu te déteste et puis tu arrives à faire
des conneries et et quand et quand enfin
tu quand tu te sens compris je sais que
les souliers il ya des gens là kim kim
qui me regardent qui savent très bien de
quoi je parle même s'ils n'ont pas les
mêmes choses que moi d'avoir ce truc
dans la tête qu'il est bouffe
quotidiennement dont ils ont dont ils ne
parlent pas et c est assez à ces gens je
dis allez voir des psychiatres si vous
tombez sur un mauvais psychiatre elle
avoir un deuxième un troisième un
quatrième un cinquième jusqu'à ce que
vous vous sentiez compris pas compliqué
trouver un bon psychiatre avant de se
casser quelqu'un qui vous comprend
si quelqu'un vous prescrit des cachets
et vous sentez au fond de vous que ça va
pas vous aider nicd pas trouver autre
chose des fois il faut des cachets je
suis pas ralenti médicaments total il ya
des maladies qui nécessite de la
médicamentation mais
parfois sur certaines formes de troubles
et de maladies parfois en vidic et
parfois non j'ai dit quoi me dis qu'ils
vont changer dit médicamentation un
médication
ça fait 2 fait longtemps que je parle là
je commence à
1h45
donc donc c'est
smc tu vois c'est tout c'est tout ça que
je voulais aussi expliqué dans le
spectacle et
c'est que ces gens se sentent compris et
puis l'alcool
l'alcool saloperie ouais c'est une
saloperie je le traite dans le spectacle
j'ai décidé de pas trop le traité de pas
trop le traité pour une simple et bonne
raison c'est que c'est toujours promis
aux gens que si je sentais que j'allais
pas être objectif sur un sujet je le
traitais pas
donc j'avais commencé à faire une truc
sur les lobbys du vin et les machins
j'avais des dos sur mon bureau comme ça
je me suis assis city je fais
et
je me suis dit tv mais en fait pour toi
ce que tu te sens victimes alors viens
le tube papa cette fois ci je le ferai
peut-être sur l'autre spectacle puisque
je pense qu'avec l'écologie bon les
vignes où je peux trouver un truc peu
fait pour accroche pour quand même l'été
de français mais en tout cas j'ai pas
voulu le faire ce que j'ai voulu faire
c'était
c'était de dire aux gens si vous avez un
problème d'addiction on peut s'en sortir
quelle que soit la diction 1 il n'y a
pas de jugement de tuco que tu prends de
l'hérault tu penses que tu veux l'alcool
tout ça c'est la même chose c'est une
addiction
donc je voulais leur dire déjà c'est pas
parce qu'ils fondèrent
mais c'est illégal la chèvre
tu vois je voulais dire aux gens je
voulais dire aux gens vous pouvez
réellement vous en sortir
sans médicaments parce que ça c'est
aussi une facilité tu vois j'ai un
problème h1 donc tacle tu vois on peut
s'en sortir de maliens par q sont
visiblement pas que son métier d'homme
et la charte je soulage par les
addictions jeu dans les addictions au
jeu par les addictions les addictions
jeudi je précise ça je ne parle que des
addictions tu parles que pour toi et je
parle que pour moi mais l'addiction je
parle uniquement de l'addiction site a
une addiction plus d'autres troubles
voilà mais ce que je dis aux gens c'est
quand même les alcooliques anonymes les
narcotiques anonymes etc etc je parle
uniquement de l'addiction si tu as un
trouble associé qui nécessite une des
médicaments évidemment je parle jus de
l'addiction les politiques de nîmes
il devrait
en tout cas c'est c'était ça le c'était
ça le truc c'est de dire aux gens vous
pouvez vous en sortir
moi j'ai traversé les alcooliques
anonymes narcotiques anonymes ce que moi
je connais un petit peu de tout des
médicaments de l'alcool et pour quoi je
parle de médicaments c'est important
parce qu'il ya plein de gens qui pensent
s'en sortir en allant dans les
médicaments et en fait c'est juste que
tu changes juste de cabine c'est pour ça
que j'apprécie ça maintenant je suis pas
en train de faire un jugement sûr ne
prenait pas de médicaments c'est je ne
suis pas médecin et c'est pas ça que je
dis juste l'addiction on peut arriver à
s'en sortir sans tomber dans les
médicaments
on commence à connaître un peu tu as une
volonté de fer quand tu te dis quelque
chose en tête tu l'a jamais
il ya des personnes je pense qu'on passe
cette recette cette volonté cc comment
expliquer ça aux gens qui nous regardent
t une machine de guerre si tu l'as
jamais il ya des gens pas dans le même
état psychique ou psychologiques que toi
c'est de leur dire leur dire bah le
traitement ça sert à rien c'est parce
que j'ai dit a reformulé lent j'ai pas
dit le traitement ça c'est rien déjà
savourer la phrase ne va rien dire parce
qu'on ne sait pas de quel traitement par
mois ce que je dis c'est que on peut se
sortir des addictions sans médicaments
c'est tout ce que je dis je dis pas ne
prenez pas de me dire que je parlerai de
quoi je parlerai les médicaments sont
nécessaires et les gens c'est pour ne
pas lever 10 km heure et les maladies
qui ne sont pas très table sans
médicaments j'ai toujours précisé qu'on
pouvait s'en sortir sans médicaments
j'ai jamais dit aux joueurs de premier
pas de médicaments c'est pas du tout bon
c'est pas du tout mon propos c'est pas
le genre à faire des petits jusqu'à ce
que je dis non mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que on peut s'en sortir sans
médicaments par exemple prenons un
exemple moi j'avais au début j'avais de
la ritaline vous dites qu de
soumission chez les gamins c'est ça qui
m'a décidé à un trouble de l'attention
hyperactivité
on m'a dit que j'étais au potentiel et c
est donc bien là combien je n'ai pas
fait la cheville et combien je sais pas
j'ai pas fait le honnêtement j'ai pas
fait un compte a dit c'est du pipeau non
j'ai fait des tests et on m'a dit vous
avez vous êtes au potentiel mais j'ai
pas demandé c'était en suisse dans le
cadre de la cure j'ai pas j'ai pas
demandé j'ai pas dit combien je sais pas
j'ai pas fait le truc en plus comme j'ai
un trou de l'attention avec
hyperactivité
le test de qi classique je peux pas
vraiment le faire parce que
non mais en fait mon cerveau tu sais ne
veux pas réfléchir à l'information donc
ça c'est l'un des troubles de
l'attention hyperactivité
donc en réalité si tu me donnes un test
classique je peux le cartonné comme
complètement échoué parce que c'est mon
cerveau qui l'a décidé à ce jour là si
mais il ya quand même de fortes chances
que si tu mets des formes ovales et
losange et que tu me disent tu me dis ça
correspond à quelle couleur il ya de
fortes chances que mon service on s'en
bat les couilles d'elvange allons faire
ça et que je te répondre autre chose
donc
attends de quoi on parle et j'ai perdu
attention oui mais on parlait de j'étais
en train de faire un jeu parlé d'un truc
avant je sais plus lequel quand on te
dit agnostique et oui voilà et donc
quand on m'a dessiné une diagnostiqué ce
problème de troubles de l'attention avec
hyperactivité c'est c'est qu'on m'a dit
le combo troubles de l'attention et
hyperactivité au potentiel c'est un
combo qui est un peu relou ça peut créer
d'autres troubles et donc c'est mon cas
d'ailleurs je suis obsessionnel
compulsif et obsessionnel idée hâtif on
pense qu explique hideo tish idée hâtif
ces
anti par départ des images alors après
des images ça peut être des images ça
peut être des ça peut être des dépenses
et des scénarios des choses en gros pour
je vais essayer de vulgariser un peu le
truc mais généralement les idées hâtif
on a des obsessions d'un des auditions
de pardon je me suis on a des
symboliques donc c'est vrai j'en sais
rien par exemple moi on pense qu'on
n'est pas sûr a complètement ça serait
la pureté qu'a priori j'aurai un genre
un délire sur la pureté donc belle mais
là mais ça va très très loin la pureté
ça peut être la pureté d'une amitié ça
peut être la pureté tout tu vois donc du
coup on pense que c'est ça mais on n'est
pas complètement complètement sûr je
vais pas dire exactement ce que j'ai
dans la tête parce que c'est personnel
ça je sache je veux pas je veux pas en
parler mais grosso modo c'est assez
simple ton cerveau il prend ta pierre
faye il prend le truc où il en a +1 il
va prendre les 5-6 sujet les pires pour
toi et il va te tard j'étais dessus
voilà et quand il en tient un le pire il
y va à fond et donc ça génère des flashs
donc ça veut dire on est en train de
parler puis d'un coup je vais avoir
l'image un truc horrible soit que
j'invente soit je vais prendre un bout
de réalité je vais imaginer sa vie
pendant l'interview d'un non pas pendant
l'interview là parce que
parce que ça va beaucoup mieux depuis
que j'ai arrêté l'alcool et depuis que
j'ai une hygiène de vie quand quand on
m'a fait ma liste de maladies figurent
des combats n'y a pas de traitement donc
ça tombait bien facile on m'a dit alors
que du coup c'est à dire j'avais de la
ritaline avant de rentrer en cure de
désintox parce qu'un psychiatre mais
donner la ritaline qui ce qui m'a
beaucoup aidé au début sauf que je suis
dépendant la ritaline c'est pas censé
être addictif je sais pas moi en tout
cas je crois que mon max jeu devant
prendre huit par jour j arrive à 15
c'est rassurer
je suis juste dépendants tu me donnes tu
me donnes ne tue si tu me donnes si tu
vas me donner chez pas une tarte aux
pommes et la tarte aux pommes elle me
fait un truc dans la tête je vais
bouffer 8 tonnes de tarte aux pommes tu
en sais juste que la ritaline ça me
faisait quelque chose donc j'ai arrêté
la ritaline et je m'en suis sorti sans
ritaline donc tu vois je suis pas c'est
ça que je veux dire c'est que je suis
pas anti médicaments je dis aux gens
qu'il ya des alternatives pas toujours
mais parfois il ya des alternatives aux
médicaments et que au maximum faut
essayer de faire sans si on peut et
cissé et si et si le médecin vous dis
oui tu peux après les médicaments ça
empêche parfois les gens de se suicider
ça on peut acheter ça guérit des
maladies évidemment mais là on
encore une fois je parle je porte dans
des cas dans des cas bien spécifiques
mais
donc le passionnel compulsif l'autre
partie de l' obsession c'est plus des
trucs compulsif alors c'est pareil c'est
un peu différent chez tout le monde tu
vois mais je sais pas par exemple
compulsif ça va être tiens mais je veux
donner un exemple assez concret un soir
j'étais jeune et j'étais dans le sud est
je vais me balader au bord d'un lac et
tout ça et puis c'est fin de journée
dont je remonte donc je suis dans ma
voiture comme ça puis j'ai mon gps etc
c'est des petites routes au bord du lac
je roule à 10 tu devras 10 km heure tu
vois et donc ils m'ont c'est pas bien
mais je suis sur mon téléphone filaire
comme ça mais je fais juste ça tu vois
je vois hein c'est pas que c'est pas
bien c'est bien il faut pas le faire et
mais je ne suis pas contre les
médicaments parce que je pense à ta
stress
donc c'est comme ça et puis on est je
relève la tête et là je vois une famille
je me rappelle très très bien je vois un
père avec ses deux petites filles en
vélo passé comme ça après deux mois
d'accord bon il ne s'est absolument rien
passé ils n'ont pas eu peur j'étais bien
sur ma droite j'ai juste fait ça
d'accord sauf que quand j'ai relevé la
tête je les avais pas vus avant de
baisser la tête donc j'ai été un peu
surpris de les voir mais ce genre de ces
domaines on l'a 47 fois par jour en
conduisant ou enfin sais je sais rien là
j'en parle donc ça semble être un
événement mais en vrai et ça va passer
j'ai juste croisé des cyclistes 10 km en
voiture bon je pars et dans ma tête ça
que sa part [__] tu imagines quand
même tu aurais rouler plus vite tout
aurait pas remonter la tête à ce moment
quand même tu aurais pu percuter donc là
c'est je commençais à voir les images de
l'accident puis j'ai une bonne
imagination
donc les deux petites filles père je les
ai bien bien bien dans ma tête j'imagine
tout le choc le bruit de la voiture qui
ai fait ça enfin tout ressortir l'odeur
du son toutou gg tout dans la tête c'est
terrible et machin tu t'es arrêté et
donc je suis un monstre attend c'est
pire que ça je roule et à un moment
donné je me dis je m'arrête et je me dis
mais en fait peut-être
peut-être c'est ce qui vient de se
passer mon cerveau l'a effacé me fait
passer ça pour une image alors qu'en
fait ça vient d'arriver et là je fais
demi tour et je vais sur les lieux pour
vêlage et là tu vois un mec tout seul
au bord de la route avec la voiture en
warning faire comme ça par terre parce
qu'il cherche le corps de la famille
après je repars et là je me dis
peut-être mon cerveau il m'a ramené pas
à l'endroit où il ya eu l'accident parce
qu'il veut pas revivre le traumatisme
donc là où j'ai vérifié c'est pas là où
ça s'est passé et après je regarde la
presse pendant trois jours en me
demandant si il va y avoir dans la
presse un article d'une famille qui
s'est fait percuter par un gars qui
s'est enfui
c'est parce que t'as pas de check it on
pare chocs pour savoir s'il est du son
ou des bons cela tout chemin en réalité
tu as raison
tu as raison mais mon cerveau va me
trouver autre chose enfin on trouve ils
vont trouver autre chose il va me dire
oui mais c'était des petites filles donc
ça s'est passé au dessus je te dis
d'avant ce qui va venir ou alors j'en ai
percuté peut-être qu'une et puis le père
et l'autre ils sont partis
ou alors la police est arrivée et je
sais pas enfin tu vois je vais je vais
de toute façon de toute façon mon
cerveau va trouver une parade à ça
j'aurais peur quoi qu'il arrive ça c'est
plutôt le côté obsessionnel compulsif
côté de sauter hyper créatif ouais ouais
bah oui pour le coup ça j'ai pas de
problème d'inspiration mais pas pour l
inspiration donc tous ces troubles la
bombe bien il ya miami law de trucs on
peut faire cinq heures dessus mais bon
dans ce spectacle j'en parle un peu plus
haut mais mais mais il se passe il se
passe un petit peu tous et tous ces
trucs là et puis après il ya ce problème
d'addiction qui vient se rajouter alors
il ya des facteurs aggravants
l'addiction tu peux avoir un point
l'addition est une maladie ça il faut
bien le rappeler aux gens c'est une
maladie c'est pas votre faute faisant
preuve d'indigence est une maladie c'est
un dérèglement de la zone de récompenses
qui vrille et qui vous en réclame plus
vous avez vous n'avez pratiquement
aucune volonté ça fait partie de la
maladie c'est tout ça tout ça est une
maladie
donc
déjà moi je ne savais pas tu vois je
sais pas que c'est une maladie quand je
suis arrivé en cure de désintox on m'a
dit bah non c'est une maladie reconnue
par l'om est depuis depuis depuis 50 ans
et plus et quand j'étais en suisse tu
vois je dis non c'est une maladie vous
êtes français
comme toujours venir oui mais mais là
c'est parce que
je sais pas en fait tout le monde avait
l'air de savoir que c'était une maladie
il ya déjà des cures de désintox en
france qui propose aux gens
d'apprendre à gérer leur consommation
alors que si tu as un vrai problème
d'addiction tu ne peux pas le gérer
c'est impossible
après la substance est addictives en
soit si je te prends je te mets dans une
pièce pendant six mois je te force à
boire une bouteille de sky tous les
jours quand je vais te ressortir des six
mois tu vas avoir une sky alors que t'es
pas forcément alcoolique tu vois donc
c'est pour ça que c'est les maladies
psychiatriques c'est compliqué parce que
par exemple moi le trouble de
l'attention avec hyperactivité
il ya beaucoup de gens il ya beaucoup de
gens qui ont des troubles d'attention et
d'hyperactivité compte des problèmes
d'alcool qui ont des problèmes
d'addiction de manière générale donc
c'est très certainement un facteur
aggravant mais peut-être que si j'avais
pas lu le trouble de l'attention avec
hyperactivité j'aurais quand même été
alcoolique peut-être ou pas on sait pas
tu vois donc et puis et puis il ya des
gens qui vont juste avoir une phase
parce qu'ils vont ils ont ils ont vécu
un drame dans leur vie alors ils font
tomber un peu dans les substances ils
deviennent a dit parce que la sucent la
substance est addictive et puis eux
peut-être qu'ils arriveront un jour art
consommé régulier de temps en temps en
étant en étant
raisonnables ce que je leur souhaite un
vrai dépendant il peut plus reprendre
ses terminal ou moi je sais que c'est
terminé
si tu me donnes une goutte la de rosé
c'est fini je vais te mentir pendant six
mois dont beau foot
azur bucquoy un vaste écran
et dans six mois tu me vois en terrasse
et je suis comme ça en train de faire
des clous et glou dd c'est sûr ça mettra
six semaines six mois six ans mais je
retomberai dedans je n'arriverai jamais
à la consommation c'est trop fort c'est
un vrai un vrai trouble mais on peut
s'en sortir et a réussi à me dire
j'ai réussi à mener dans un spectacle
j'ai essayé de gg oui de toute façon tu
pouvais pas ne pas en parler j'avais un
spectacle sur la santé donc je me suis
dit je peux pas je peux pas avoir vécu
tout ça et ne pas en parler parce que
moi ce qui m'a sauvé c'est d'en parler
et l'alcool et les troubles les deux
c'est d'en parler donc je me suis dit
forcément ça va faire du bien aux gens
forcément ça va leur faire du bien c'est
obligatoire
le
le principal problème de n'importe quels
troubles de ce type de ce que tu peux
avoir c'est que cette idole
quand tu as une bouteille avec toi est
alcoolique une a besoin de personne
clé un peu de personnes juste à
bouteilles c'est pour ça que
malheureusement souvent les familles les
proches je pense que les gens qui nous
regardent ce soir qu'ils savent de quoi
je peins vont s'épuiser à essayer de
parfois même forcer les gens à arrêter
et ça ne sert à rien il ya que toi qui
peux prendre la décision d'arrêter tes
proches ils doivent de soutenir t'aimer
t'écouter évidemment mais il ya que toi
qui peux décider d'arrêter et il n'y a
pas de solution miracle sa part il n'ya
pas il n'y a pas de solution miracle si
tu veux arrêter il faut arrêter les mois
je conseille beaucoup les groupes de
parole parce que d'après ce que j'ai lu
je mets entre guillemets mais d'après ce
que j'ai lu c'est c'est l'un des trucs
les plus efficaces si ce n'est pour dire
le à peu près le seul truc qui
fonctionne parce que c'est très dur de
s'en sortir l'alcool fait partie des
trucs les plus compliquées pour s'en
sortir parce que tu avais quand je
disais sans médicamentation par exemple
ça l'important je vais repréciser ça
quand même l'héroïne et l'alcool je
crois à la penderie même et je suis
pratiquement sûr de ce que je dis c'est
à peu près les deux seuls droits que tu
ne peux pas arrêter d'un coup sans
médicamentation par exemple alors
médicale j'aurais pas dire
médicamentation de médication par
exemple l'alcool quand tu arrêtes que tu
as beaucoup concours de d'alcool ouais
on te file une vitamine je sais plus le
nom je sais plus laquelle mais je vous
le dis si vous avez beaucoup beaucoup
d'alcool renseignez-vous quand même
avant avec votre médecin
juste sur cette vitesse il faut prendre
une vitamine quand t'arrêtes pas ce que
ça va très vite et voilà et l'héroïne
souvent ils concèdent qui substitue
qu'on va arrêter petit à petit pour pour
au final ne plus ne plus ne plus rien
comprendre mais par exemple moi quand je
suis arrivé sur de désintox tu vois
naïvement je pensais que moi je prenais
pas cocaïne bref j'en avais pris une
fois dans ma vie on est pris pendant 12h
jeu devenu cinglé mais sinon mes amis
non mais tu vois voilà je n'ai jamais
pris de cocaïne de ma vie et puis un
jour tu sais pas c'est que la cocaïne
grotte de cookies ne faut pas prendre de
cocaïne le ce qui s'est passé avec la
cocaïne c'est un fan à moi qui me
croisent dans la rue j'ai tenté rage me
rappellerai toute ma vie et qui ont fait
une petite photo de lui et puis il dit
je t'ai mis un petit cadeau dans ta
poche et je rentre à la maison c'est à
bordeaux je buvais c'était un an avant
de rentrer en cure de désintox donc ce
n'était pas proche était forte je
n'étais pas en phase de sobriété là pour
le compléter en plus tôt qu'on fasse
d'eux devra de consommation forte et je
rentrais touchette avec un pote et puis
j ou fait il me dit quoi dans la poche
et c'était de la cocaïne je n'ai jamais
pris de ma vision façon je risque quoi
c'est j'ai 30 ans je vais plus tomber là
dedans alors s'en rende compte que
j'étais déjà complètement les coliques
un bac si la phrase est folle je voulais
pas tomber là dedans avec un d'ailleurs
des jeunes descendus quatre bouteilles
dans la journée j pris une trace de sa
fille ah ça c'est bien non c'est mon
truc ça je suis devenu fou incapable de
m'arrêter j'en ai pris toute la nuit et
le truc le plus dingue c'est là où tu
vois que le cerveau est vraiment malade
c'est que du coup j'en avais jamais
acheter
j'ai traîné mon pote en boîte pour
sortir et tout ça et j'étais lui je suis
sûr il en est bien jouer à chaque fois
j'étais dans le mille tellement mon
cerveau on voulait tellement il a mis
tout on a on a ouvert comme ça j'avais
des des analyses de machin truc c'est
que tu vas pas la folie du truc donc
lumbrois pour moi c'est vraiment ton
cerveau qui devient ont fait vient sont
donc il faut ré à me donner tu vois
j'ai travaillé ou douanes
mais tu vois ce que je veux dire c'est
que c'est ça qu'il faut faire comprendre
aux gens c'est que
c'est vraiment un dérèglement il peut se
contrôler il peut se maîtriser mais tu
as beau aimer la personne tu as beau lui
dire je t'en supplie arrête arrête
arrête c'est par là que ça passe et
c'est pas de la faute des gens c'est
s'est pas non plus de la faute de celui
qui boit il faut juste prendre la
décision d'arrêter mais c'est d'abord un
combat personnel on a besoin des proches
on a besoin d'eux mais je veux dire moi
j'avais des gens incroyablement aimant
autour de moi compréhensifs ça me
faisait quand même pas arrêter le jour
où j'ai arrêté c'est parce que j'ai eu
peur de me jeter par la fenêtre j'ai
senti que j'avais sauté et je me suis en
fait je veux pas mourir par contre ce
qui m'a fait tenir et ce qui m'a aidée
par la suite c'est cet amour que j'avais
autour de moi et ce qui m'a aidé a pas
sauté par la fenêtre c'est que je savais
que tous ces gens autour de moi même et
donc ça ne sert pas à rien mais si ça
marche pas c'est pas de votre faute quoi
parce que c'est ça passe quand même par
une une conviction personnelle très très
forte
est ce que tu es trois bouquins
conseillé à notre communauté
ah ça fait longtemps les trucks de trucs
de trucks parce que ça fait longtemps
que t'as pas lu toute chose que tes
sources ouais en fait ça fait très très
longtemps que j'ai pas lu ça fait
vraiment longtemps que j'ai pas lu un
truc
qu'est ce que je pourrais conseiller
si ça fait très longtemps que t'as pas
t'as pas lu je lis beaucoup d'articles
et touche dit très peu de bouquins
conseil trois films
à ça je peux alors
le formidable musique tron ont trois
enfants vous êtes bien assez bien les
films des musiques souvent je l'essayé
musique mais des sims et bien
non mais les vrais du couchant son avis
sur ce les bouquins sont restés bloqués
soit les bouquins non mais je pourrais
conseiller des bouquins mais
mais mais mais mais les films mais les
films c'est les films c'est chouette
parce que c'est vrai que je lis que des
trucs en ce moment beaucoup de jus de
témoignages de machin on comprend le
problème je dis très peu de romans et
tout je suis pas un grand lecteur
les films alors on a je vais conseil à
un film je déconseille parasite
un film c'est un film coréen je crois
c'est ça
incroyable il faut absolument voir ça je
vais je vais je vais proposer un
deuxième film coréen
qui s'appelle
j'ai rencontré le diable
c'est un club c'est le réalisateur avec
qui je travaille en ce moment c'est une
belle tibia qui m'a conseillé je rend à
césar ce qui appartient à césar ce film
qui est incroyable alors bon c'est un
peu gore et où c'est un film de genre un
espèce de film d'horreur et tout mais
c'est c'est c'est incroyable et puis je
ne peux pas ne pas parler de mon film
préféré qui est le grand bleu j'ai dû
voir
75 fois que je mets en est parfois en
fou pour m'endormir que je connais par
coeur comme je ne sais pas ce que m'a
fait ce film et j'ai vu je crois je
crois l'avoir rouge des juges de vingt
huit ans je crois vraiment je les ai vus
sans une fois j'en sais rien et là en
plus on m'avait invité à aller voir eric
serra en ce moment fait visiter oui oui
pardon le compositeur du grand bleu
entre autres un il a composé plein
d'autres choses mais l'a fait en ce
moment une tournée du grand bleu ou avec
un orchestre sur scène et où les
musiques du grand bleu et je pourrais
pas y aller puisque je pars la semaine
prochaine pour jouer à tahiti à nouméa
et après je suis en tournée donc je
pourrais pas y aller mais je vais quand
même essayer de trouver une date pour y
aller mais voilà c'est le grand bleu
c'est
que je sais pas expliquer pourquoi ce
film m'a transcendé à ce point là mais
c'est je trouve ce film totalement
bouleversante
de a à z est-ce que tu as un conseil
pour les jeunes générations
oui
que je peux vraiment leur dire
c'est que
je vais leur sortir cette fameuse phrase
très cliché de tout est possible parce
que je pense que c'est vrai avec une
certaine lucidité si tu n'as pas de
jambes on va éviter de vouloir être
coureur par exemple évidemment faut être
aussi lucide de c&c de ses aptitudes et
ses compétences mais j'ai des choses à
dire par rapport à la france ah bon il a
dit aux français tout est possible il
est dit l'édile faut être conscient
aussi que représente 2 5 watts ah oui
non mais disons que parce que parce que
c'est bien beau de dire aux gens tout
est possible après s'il faut quand même
être il faut une fois il faut en fait il
faut allier la lame de l'humidité
énormément de ténacité l'humilité ça
permet de se rendre compte est ce que
vraiment je suis fait pour ça ou pas
mais la ténacité c'est primordial je
pense que
il faut lâcher prise sur ce qu'on ne
peut pas maîtriser ça c'est une phrase
de les gens qui ont fait
des intox il doit faire avec la frappe
oui c'est la phase d intox faut lâcher
prise et il faut s'acharner
s'acharner sur ce qu'on veut parce que
il ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de gens
le talent est très important pour
réussir je veux faire partie de ces
artistes lisent le talent c'est 5% de
nangis pas complètement d'accord le
talent c'est quand même important pour
réussir et quand on a la chance de
trouver son talent par contre j'ai
convaincu tout on a un talent ça j'en
suis convaincu quand on a la chance de
trouver son talent bon ça va quand même
plus vite mais on peut vraiment
avec un peu moins de talent et beaucoup
plus de travail il peut arriver à des
objectifs bien supérieure et puis
surtout un don il faut désacraliser le
côté dont mes talents un talent ça
augmente un don on peut le rendre plus
fort l'écriture par exemple moi je suis
beaucoup je suis bien meilleur en
écriture maintenant qu'il ya dix ans
voilà jeunes femmes certainement un
petit talent de base mais j'ai tellement
travaillé mon écriture que je suis bien
meilleur dans l'écriture maintenant donc
un don ou un talent ou une aptitude
c'est comme tout avec le travail ça
augmente et exactement comme les
maladies invisible c'est pas parce que
c'est quelque chose d'impalpable que ça
n'existe pas c'est le travail c'est pas
seulement la salle de sport le travail
c'est aussi dans des choses comme ça
c'est aussi des choses parfois un petit
peu impalpable tout ce travail donc je
pense sincèrement qu'avec date de la
ténacité de l'humilité et du travail on
peut arriver à faire des choses
incroyables tu as des dettes à nous
conseiller quand tu vas jouer les dettes
des dates à
ta des dettes le conseiller
des dates ben écoute l'ag balaj et haïti
et nouméa tu nous aides vous n'avez pas
venir alors ce que je peux au propre
alors paris alors là j'ai une grande
tournée des zénith qui démarre fin au
temps passé dans toutes les grandes
toutes les grandes villes de france et
puis on va terminer à paris ça ça va
être le gros événement pro pour moi
c'est qu'on a décidé de terminer par
bercy donc on va faire deux bercy les 9
et 10 mars 2024 ce sera les dernières
absolue du spectacle on a décidé de
finir à bercy pour plein de raisons il
ya évidemment légaux la revanche
personnelle le regarder chez bercy ils
vont il ya tout ça dedans on va pas se
mentir ça fait partie du package et puis
il ya aussi
ce spectacle qu'a démarré avec en
vendant cent mille billets d'avant sans
aucune promo et puis qui s'arrête et
puis on redémarre et on est en fait les
gens n'ont pas donc n'ont pas demandé
d'hambourg seulement des billets donc
j'ai pu faire ma tournée deux ans après
comme si rien n'avait bougé c'était
incroyable de vivre ça et je voulais
marquer le coup on nous a enfermés nous
a empêchés de jouer je voulais faire un
truc de et voilà on soirée puis puis
parce que bercy va nous permettre de
faire beaucoup de surprises beaucoup de
trucs incroyables donc évidemment c'est
les deux dates que je que je mets le
plus en avant parce que je pense que ça
va être fou de vivre ces deux dernières
avec un spectacle qui a cahotant qui m'a
autant bouleverser car autant
bouleverser les gens aient tout fait
voilà c'est un ovni ce père qui dure 2
heures 5 enfin j'ai jamais autant donné
sur scène que dans ce spectacle j'ai
jamais mis autant mon coeur mes couilles
qu'un les replacer tu vas y lever les
tripes sur la table qu'avec ce spectacle
j'ai jamais j'ai jamais autant donné
sanaa j'ai jamais autant entendu les
gens rire autant les gens pleurer autant
de gens c'est un truc ce spectacle pour
les jeux et je veux vivre ça dans une
salle avec beaucoup de monde parce que
j'ai vécu dans les salles très petit
parce que c'est bien moi je fais toutes
les salles et je veux vivre ça comme ça
et donc cette tournée des zéniths aussi
va être
incroyable donc là j'ai fait sans dida
dans des salles est dans des salles de
300 à 2000 donc petites/moyennes grand
et la la la tournée des zénith elle va
être incroyable parce que là on ad on a
des scores fou en zénith donc on va être
entre trois et cinq mille par ville on a
mis tout ce qu'il fallait pour que tout
le monde voit bien on a mis des on a
fait tout en sorte pour que et ça va
être ça va être fou de vivre ça avec
autant de gens parce qu'il ya des
moments tellement intense que j'ai hâte
de vis avec autant de gens jérémy
ferrari merci
[Musique]
com
m
[Musique]